tout le monde salue maxime salut à tous
la team gulf stream dans la place à
maxime ça fait juste super plaisir de
t'avoir pour le commentaire elle va
c'est cool moi je suis je suis content
d'être là bon un peu crevé en prévision
des prochains tournois mais là ça va tu
es crever davance de ton calendrier
c'est ça eh ben je peux te dire qu on
est crevé davance à savoir qu'on va
qu'on va commenter des trucs aussi tu
vois donc c'est cool ben ouais tu n'es
pas le seul à être fatigués de ton
calendrier qui est bien mais je m
empresse complètement complètement
complètement aimé mais j'avais fait un
objectif 300 seul pour te suivre sur le
norwich est ce qu'il n'ya pas qui n'a
pas fonctionné
voilà donc on ne suivra pas sur le
norwich est ce pour le grand chef tour
je sais pas mais pour les grands prix
dommage
reach est aussi les arméniens dans au
moins ouais faut essayer
on fera peut-être des cdd petit des
petites vidéos dans la serrurerie ouais
mais ouais les armes à gagner ouais ça
va être sympa c'est j'ai pas du tout ce
que ça va donner puisque la cadence est
inhabituel alors bon déjà la cadence
lente à inhabituel je crois que ces deux
heures 40
enfin l'an passé deux heures pour la
partie après 40e tas de 10 secondes par
coup non il est déjà les sports et
ensuite un mag et dont un cas nul s'est
dit miser montres sacrés ouais tu penses
il faut prendre les blancs ou les noirs
bah de toute façon tu as pas le choix tu
inverse la couleur mais enfin de la
partie longue mais cette dépense je
pense que c'est un truc ou magnus va
être très très chiant jarry non il va
être très très faim quand il aura li
blanc il va être très très dur à obtenir
avec les 30 min de retard et avec qui
passer
ouais je pense que c'est ça être un un
des joueurs les plus chiants bon normal
mais sinon ouais instinctivement j'en ai
fait quelques-uns d'entraînement bon
avec jules je trouvais que c'était pas
si mal d'avoir les noirs mais parce que
tu as les trois mandats partir du 60e
quand même qui est bien donc toi tu
préférais les noirs quand même ouais
après c'est une intuition c'est pas non
plus je pense que c'est pas valable
contre tout le monde
ça doit dépendre des joueurs descendent
quand manu je pense que je préférerais
quand même avoir le blanc - tu joues
pour gagner et tu voyages faudra trouver
des trucs un peu spéciaux etc
bon après ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
tenir la partie longue avec les normes
quelque chose qui dormait le passé
récent n'est pas si facile à faire quand
magnus mais mais bon après si une
nouvelle cadence voilà c'est deux heures
pour la partie i bon mais ça doit de
favoriser sa non dans une cadence chaos
comme ça toi qui es bon en activité et
où ouais moi ça me fait kiffer ça après
voilà faut voir comment tout le monde
s'adapte en fait moi saadé d'habitude
aussi de plutôt bien géré mon temps dans
le stif est que en général je pense
qu'il me restait à peu près 15 minutes
au 40e dans cette partie mais je pense
pas que ce sera le cas tout le monde et
si tu arrives avec 15 minutes compte
cinq
au 40e même avec les dix on parcourt les
mecs vont être en paix msp aussi il faut
gérer les post toilettes et c'est pas de
ta pas de temps de restructuration après
le 40e aussi à moi je dis moi j'ai une
petite bouteille en plastique avec un
tuyau et c'est comme comme les
supporters de foot un tueur est un ouais
mais il manquera la canette de bière
wave en claquettes voyait quoique cicr
s'est autorisé sa question c'est
autorisé de boire de l'alcool pendant
les parties
je crois pas maintenant je prends bien
tard mais c'est va juste dit à personne
qui le fait bien évidemment enfin ce
secret assez étrange mais georges d'un
point d'un point de vue de règlement est
ce que m mais je crois que c'est
interdit aux - parme et charte d'éthique
mais mais peut-être pas bon je dois dire
que je me suis jamais renseigné sur la
question il peut
c'est pas c'est un ouf très intelligent
pendant la porte toujours dans le chat
qui demandait ce que vladimir est pas
siffler anecdotes championnat de russie
par l'équipe 2009
donc il ya pendant trois jours à chaque
fois que je vois vlad en train de jouer
il semble en alcool
ouais et puis un jour je le joue je suis
à parier j'arrive à la partie et là il
arrive frais comme un gardon à nous ils
pas bu une goutte la veille sur une
grosse partie et je crois qu'ils étaient
mieux finalement fait nul mais voilà à
et ça commence cette partie alors
attends c'est parti ça m'étonne pas ton
anecdote il était toujours très motivé
pour jouer contre toi on savait que
c'était la raison est que c'était genre
le gros joueur français donc c'est ouais
c'est ça vient de chailly marche un peu
comme si mal c'est un peu comme un gris
chaud que je prouve
de ce point de vue là moi ils marchent
challenge ouais bah c'est pour sa grille
tout va être si dangereux d'ailleurs
pour les donc ce débute donc ouais tu
parles nous un peu du match des deux
joueurs parce que qu'elle étale sur sur
wii et prague ananda parents est
vraiment petit sur la caméra d'ailleurs
voilà ça ne vaut pas les caméras mais
ouais bah je les ai vus radio oui je
n'arrive jamais à prononcer son nom de
prague ananda c'est ça je ne me
prononcerai pas ceux là dessus maxime
ouais donc toujours est il que ouais je
l' ai vu au top 12
j'ai dû le voir aussi à lille demain je
pense en ce qu'ils et elles voilà dont
il est très jeune ce qui fait que bon il
avait forcément atteint un super niveau
maintenant voilà je le trouve pas
forcément même le plus impressionnant
parmi les indiens
ouais
bon alors après mon cas je veux un peu
plus jeune encore
mais bon il est super fort mes gonds
katchina mail nous avec femmes on avait
fait des vidéos sur google chez / praga
d'hendaye vous avez plus impressionné
coût cash
ouais bah c'est aussi par rapport à la
gym maintenant deux mois encore
oui mais même dans le style n'en ses
plaies ouais après ils vont me donner
des prédictions après en plus ce qui est
bien là maintenant c'est qu'on commence
à voir des français aussi qui vont
pouvoir rivaliser
tu penses à morisi et matériels
j'imagine haut à même le vôtre le
cannois augustin droit bah il est pas
mal
ouais non il ya du potentiel bon après
même je sais j'ai eu ouïe dire qu'il ya
des petits en moins de 8 mais bon là
c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour se
prononcer déjà moi même moins de
quatorze moins de 16 tu sais jamais
vraiment ouais tu sais jamais ce que ça
donnera après voilà c'est sympa de se
dire que tu ailles relève potentielle
puisque ya eu un assez gros trou
générationnel village envie de bien là
depuis le mans 81 10 mois est depuis
toit en fait ouais traitement il ya eu
vraiment un rôle et qui a le même âge
ouais bah oui oui mais toi en fait à
plus tard
tu as un peu percé sur le tard ouais
ouais c'est facile de dire ça j'étais
2007 à 18 ans quand même près j'ai une
grosse période de stagnation mais non
mais je veux dire percée papa sur le
fait d'être arrivé au top mais percé
dans le top 20 top 10 soit on aurait pu
penser à mon ami que tu avais tu as
atteint un plafond
un peu comme un tous peuvent par exemple
ouais bon alors après encore une fois
tout beau fils est jeune il a à peine 22
ans aime beaucoup
ouais après il y avait eu aussi des
trucs et l affaire de la triche là qui
m'avait un peu un peu mieux en dansant
dans une année donc après je mettais pas
mal refaite
ensuite à partir moi j'ai percé je
dirais en 2003 du coup ouais
après quand tu as quand tu as fait ta
deuxième percée c'est un peu comment les
mêlées quoi tu as fait une deuxième
poussée
là ça fait mal ouais ouais mais j'avais
eu une grosse crise
ouais je sais même plus trop quoi est
due cette de début 2015 mais c'est vrai
je vais bien rattrapé en fin 2015 mais
donc
ouais donc pour en revenir on était à
prague ananda tous ces joueurs là et toi
tu parles française oui bah forcément
non mais c'est juste j'en suis venu à la
roulotte française que je veux dire bon
c'est sympa de voir les indiens et
chinois les usa et ses terres à se
battre mais on a envie un peu d'eau à
bah oui je fais une firme cd coûte 1
je te confirme je te confirme après il
faudra peut-être du matériel quand je
prends ma retraite est du coup tu
cherches déjà qui tue seconde ratu pense
d'ailleurs à ça j'en sais rien je suis
vraiment beaucoup trop tôt honnêtement
je pense pas que je seconde ray mais je
serai prêt à filer des coups de main
quoi plutôt vrai tu seras en fait c'est
vrai que ça fait tellement longtemps
qu'on n'a pas eu un joueur français de
ton niveau
ça fait vraiment longtemps web un
français français ça fait trois cents
ans
ouais c'est ça ma jeffrey lindor je
pense que phoebe d'or c'est tout mais
voilà là on est d'accord on est d'accord
là dessus parce que tu as souvent
du coup tu tues à douvres cette position
souvent on me demande est ce que tu es
le plus grand joueur français tous les
temps bon déjà il ya blad mais c'est
hors catégorie pour ça rien je la lis
les français kazako russie les îles est
partout partout mais oui mais après très
sérieusement parlant je dis souvent que
je pense que philidor
ça reste quand même le patron a le sens
où après on cite beaucoup avec in espace
qui j'ai envie de dire non parce que bon
en tant que français
ouais puis puis dans ces cas là tu peux
tu peux citer n'importe qui quand il
suffit qu'un mec soit naturalisés et
puis tu le site à l'école française sais
pas si c'est ça après on doit beaucoup
l'école de ryes directement
indirectement mois plus indirectement je
pense que n'diaye c'était plus
directement via iossif un bon mois après
j'ai eu nicolas spiridonov et j'ai aussi
eu ensuite des coachs enfin tout ce que
etienne a gagné aussi en expérience
quand après je me suis retrouvé en
concurrence avec lui et c'est un bon
bref voilà l'école soviétique nous a
aidés clairement un donc l'école
française c'est d'école soviétique en
fait on a beaucoup de deux
ressortissants soviétiques qui sont
venus vivre en balance aussi
ouais ils ont ils ont ils ont ils ont
influencé donc pour repartir pour le
moment sur la présentation des horreurs
histoire de tu vois on y reviendra de
face il y aura plein de questions avec
le chat et huayi du coup un joueur
ba qui pourrait être champion du monde
un jour non ouais ben alors après oui
c'est ça c'est aussi un phénomène que
j'aime pas dans le sens 20 pas lui mais
je m'exprime mal mais je sais voisine on
met un temps fait comme si tu étais où
il oublie qu'il ya du stream que les
gens regardent et où tu t'en fous tu
fais ta phrase on s'en fout pas si c'est
oui non mais je disais oh oui donc en
bas quand il avait 13 ans le clip qui
m'a battu déjà voilà tout le monde la
double en tant que futur champion du
monde là depuis pendant 2 3 1 il a
stagné mais bon stagné au delà de 2007
et puis les gens disaient aube et ça y
est il est plus dans les fringues magnus
et c'est avant tout ça c'est du blabla
cette culture de l'instant qui corrompt
vraiment bien plus les autres sports
mais également également le notw a eu
mon prêt évidemment quand et spectateurs
devant ta télé est avide de faire des
commentaires comme ça mais dans la
réalité il ya quand même pas mal de jeu
serait bien d'avoir un peu un peu de
recul sur ces trucs là un peu de
constance quoi par rapport à voilà et
donc oui j'ai clairement c'est un mec
qui peut devenir champion du monde même
si voilà depuis il a eu trois ans un peu
plus difficile bon il a il n'a même pas
20 voix il a peut-être qui vient d'avoir
20 ans ouais voilà ça te pose le truc
quoi il a 20 ans et tu l'as vu à abidjan
d'ailleurs ouais il joua besoin s'est
bien passé pour moi comprimé mais ce
n'était pas le cas avant donc ouais
c'est un joueur à surveiller en fait
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi dans sur
ceux sur cette chose des masterclasses
maintenant tout le monde part de fille
ruth châssis rouge raf crew chiefs iron
man c'est eh oui des séries mondiales
ouais on sait on sait pas en fait non
mais t'as tellement mecs qui sont
c'est bruce aussi personne ne connaît
pas des sarts anna les machins ici
piankov un way et sip ngokwey
mais ouais puis tu as est à des petits
jeunes quoi puisque j'ai oublié les
petits jeunes russes des petits jeunes
ouzbeks aussi qui sont supérieures sont
bons elle est signe d' art of absous
doctorow ouais c'est ça voilà les cds et
là il ya une partie un peu animé donc
bon il a pris en g7 avec en jouant sur
sur un carré d'as sahab lâchait 5 et l'a
ensuite il a mal engagé kf4 ce qui fait
la gaffe ou prend 1,4 et dame prend h3
qui est possible avec des complications
bon après il ya la pulpe des cinq pour
l'instant emprise donc peut-être ça ça
va mais j'aurais pajot kf4 du coup je
rejoue un truc plus ça y est parvenu en
b2 la voilà ça c'est je pense qu'il est
encore mieux avec les blancs ce que va y
avoir du dam g4 pas voilà il a pour le
moment matériellement on en est où il a
quand même un pion de plus ouais il un
point de plus oui nombril en bonne
il est en bonne posture ans comme on
track la sabam h5 j'aime pas ce coup il
ya tours 5
du coup de vois pas l'intérêt voilà
d'ailleurs j'aurais triangle 3 si je
pouvais me y avait peut-être payé f5
c'est pour ça du t2 il va faire quoi
faire d'un f3 damien traille à quelle
idée de déjà là une petite fourchette
away du coup un bilan d un bon alors il
n'y a pas d'épreuve 3 on évite faut
prendre qu'à ça c'est le seul point
positif de ce petit car enfin palmarès
si on refait tout 8 on a on a 30 ans
alors il n'y a pas d'âme des six ya des
quatre mois je pense au foie je suis au
fascisme a tué ou peut-être l'enfermer
mais non ou encore par fo qui joue plus
vite là le petit le petit bras chess
ouais enfin bon c'est 25 secondes contre
18 s'est pas non plus non mais il peut
peut-être il peut peut-être le taper là
s'ils accélèrent parce qu'il est une
mauvaise connexion envoyé un geste aussi
ouais tiens faut être un peu
fait un peu mal mais ce qu'il a une
bonne connexion provenant d'assez peu
sur sa faim mais là il a les quatre ils
allaient 4 bar ilan et kaba nialé kaba
baisse et là tu te dis tu te dis oui
très très fort sur internet qui vinyle
regarde les connexions fait ce qu'on
peut quoi on se bat avec ses armes
donc là il a pris une qualité là sans
doute pour eux de ce qu'ils mangent et
3.5 à éponger sur le mât du couloir
ouais et découvre la saru la voie non il
appelle une bonne connexion ce que tu
vois il est dans ce genre là de 2nde
nature français 6 évidemment je pense
que c'est fini
fou des cas c'est la montée mais elle
est reste une pièce de moi et ça va
abandonner
ça tangue de temps donc 1-0 il ya quand
même 500 points d'écart sur une chaise
comme un tu as et wallet c'est énorme
c'est une ride après c'est vrai nom mais
voyez c'est un bon client
il avait fait un départ assez canon à
abidjan en rapide en blitz il est resté
assez solide je crois qu'ils finissent 5
ou 6e au final et c'est vrai cette
histoire qui la seconde et dingli rennes
et je crois qu'ils la seconde et ouais
bah déjà la coupe du monde je crois que
tous les chinois étaient un peu resté il
te fait un hommage d'ailleurs oui bah
majorque pour ça que je dois tu connais
pas mal là non qui joue pas comme gré
choc avec fo 3 poule g simple qui jouent
comme la cas sur foot d3e 5 c'est pas
terrible je suis quand tu conseilles tu
conseilles de jouer comment surtout des
trois matchs contre le meilleur c'est lg
6 mai en faire un beau coup de pub et un
fils keto et a joué un peu car hélas
comme un dragon
ouais celle là j'avais perdu en fait qu
on n'a qu'à les jeux faut aussi ce qui
est des cinq francs
après c'est peut-être aussi la partie de
brita je sais plus vide a peut-être joué
entre comme ça emmenez peau est donc là
il fait j'ai si souvent avec le fawcett
qui bloque le cavern
après le cahier angers trop et mal placé
mais bon là tu joues un truc
fois-çi 6 h 3 mais bon après c'est
jamais dramatique mais pour mémoire
d'ailleurs peut-être pas fois je suis
pas fan en fait deux fois 6
est ce que tu peux faire un plan genre
admettons tour eu un cavalier afin
cavalli enfin foucher cinq cavaliers e3
et jouer la case des 5 pouces est un peu
lente
bah ouais non ça tu peux c'est souvent
le cas en fait quand adrian b3 nature
paix ratures perdre de temps mais tu te
replaces qu après ce que j'aime pas ici
c'est le talent font des trois ans et il
est mal placé pour ceux là il faudrait
qu'ils soient en soyant c4 à la rigueur
du coup ils jouent faux à 6h trois mois
l'envisageait pts accueille des cinq
épreuves pions prend pièce après jouer à
tenter un f4 quelque part je m'échappais
pas trop si ça marche et kelly c6
généralement même pas faire ça quand le
pion est encore en a deux pour quelle
raison parce que quand il y en a 80 ans
b4 compliqué que ça c'est assez simple
je comprends quoi et du coup là par
exemple pays des 5 alors là le purin
4chan jeu changera peut-être pas
grand-chose puisque de toute façon tu
viendrais plan b 4 mais est-ce qu'avec
les noirs tu peux jouer un joueur pour
prise prie aime ta pas tant de faire f 5
c'est ça le problème
ouais esprit sky les huit mois tu veux
te prendre 24 ans fait donc là tu es là
tu es de barante que je voulais faire je
voulais jon kyl et 5 au lieu 2 h 3 en
fait sur un projet aurait joué faut
aussi s'en fait alors si vous aussi
savent 4 comprend des cadres puis payer
cette quille ou 5 etc
à tel point schiste mais ça c'est donc
ici en gros tu as joué avec les nerfs tu
fous tu fais fouet faut aussi ce quand
même faut aussi ce que j'aime pas trop
sais que tu vas prendre en recettes en
fait est de prendre ta phu g5 tatouage
qui est chiant quand j'ai montré un je
vais montrer sargeant est donc là du
coup il obtient la position d'un là j'ai
envie de dire f4 c'est super bon chemin
ah bah c'est exactement ce exact
la position dont on parlait ouais tu
peux commencer par le d2 aussi est ce
que dans ces cas là on oublie ce genre
quand tu as le choix entre un coup comme
f4 dam des deux tu conseilles d'en
choisir un des deux rapidement parce que
toute façon tu peux pas trop calculer ou
tu conseilles 2 2 quand même un peu
calculé réfléchir et s'est trouvé plus
précis en moi je marche beaucoup à
l'instinct patent gérer l'un ou l'autre
quoi ouais d'un à trois c'est bizarre
non
ouais après je comprends une énergie 500
cavaliers h5 mais j'aime pas du tout
genre l'ajout pays des sept qu'il s'est
fait 50 pays ces cinq qui procède d'un
de prendre cette île envie de dire tu
vas faire quoi
matt a du mal à attaquer sur les cases
noires en réalité 39 5 4 ouais elle
scindant suis pas g5 une péché mignon je
vous enfermez le fourmillement
n'atteignant fermé des fonds à six en
fait ouais bah tout le monde
oui mais on n'y arrive pas te donne une
fois l'orage six bombes ou on le laisse
en vie quoi fin on fait ce qu'on peut
quoi mais ouais non mesdames f3 web
donne l'impression qu'après qu'il est ça
ne fonctionne pas voilà un bon alors
qu'est ce qui peut faire et ce qu'il
peut faire quelque chose d'autre
b4 très important tu peux pas laisser
faire réaliser cinq victimes dont il
fait gagner 5 70 inquiétude c'est qui
menacera quoi de prendre le fou de cases
blanches et du coup 9,58 est à 58 ou
alors au site à des invités incessantes
adecco comme fou g5 qui arrive c'est que
maintenant tu appliques et ir4 tapis tu
contre la casse de 4 et tu peux jouer un
coup avec les blancs ici
deux types genre c4 avec l'idée sur
cavani c5 de jouer poussée de et préparé
après à des 4 1 à 5
inquiète tu fais à 5 ans et tu fixes ok
on a rien à jeter f5 et la pac elysées 5
mai fois de suite qu'ils aimeraient bien
ou là maintenant vous prend une cuite
questi se passe il faut pas évident
surtout reprend réfute acquis et prend
des six des produits sains réagissent
ranger cette occasion près de 7 et
surtout cavaliers prend dams est qu'ils
regagnent le cavalier sur le thème
prends reprend 1,6 d'arrêts à faire pour
tirer avantage du du président chinois
ça c'était chaud mon programme dallas
qui est déconnecté en fait les deux ont
des problèmes de connexion aujourd'hui
ouais ouais ouais c'est ça il ya plus
les 4 barres alors la dalle et par son
parti elle a une barbe
voilà ça c'est hélas bord restait un pls
mais toi toi quand tu quand tu joues
comme ça c'est ma sur internet est ce
que ça te frustre les la connexion des
scuds foncia qui devrait avoir une règle
ou quoi qui a je sais pas vraiment ce
qui pourrait avoir comme règle mais 50
et spectateurs c'est vraiment frustrant
de suivre un match comme ça est un
joueur qui perd par des connexions enfin
c'est relou quoi je vais en tant que
joueur comment ça se passe ouais bah
après ouais en tant que joueur essaye de
faire au mieux on était en déplacement
tu peux pas gérer
d'ailleurs ceux qui ont tenté de se
connecter pendant mon stream à breda
désole encore je pouvais rien faire ça
ça arrive est bon après quand je suis
chez moi j'ai d'afim pour que la
connexion des rice et c'est pas prêt
d'arriver ici j'ai eu un problème en
trois ans non mais sérieux rival des
fournisseurs mais bon ça ça arrive ça tu
peux rien y faire
mais du coup et c'est là la 4g pour way
en sécurité 6 et si ça arrive à ton
adversaire dans le match ça te frustre
aussi genre brut est content tu prends
le point
bah c'est pas c'était pas très c'est pas
grave mais bon ça fait partie du jeu
quoi c'est comme quand tu gagnes sur son
téléphone
oui oui enfin moi je suis de cet avis
aussi si je peux gagner n'importe
comment
quand tu es dans le match après a
posteriori tu dis toujours c'est plus
beau de gagner proprement mais pendant
que tu es dans tes dents quoi fin ouais
bah tu prends deux points je sais que
les mots la sonnerie de téléphone et
sorbo conneries même gaffe à la con
wiarton adversaire s'endort si tu ça ça
n'arrive pas mais quasiment pas ouais ça
arrive qu'au meilleur de s'endormir et
d'ailleurs on informe que en fait en
nouvelle donc l'armageddon
et avec la même couleur donc ça ne verse
pas des couleurs ouais donc ses actifs
au mieux jouer magnus avec les blancs du
coup mal du coup oui parce qu'en plus
avec les blancs tu peux c'est mieux
d'avoir les blancs conclut créé moi en
ce moment et ça s à petit sa petite
flèche nikop17 c'est inquiète pas non il
la joue bien ça il ajoute bien mais tu
pense qu'il ya moyen de ya moyen de
faire des trucs quoi bosser c'est comme
manager je la joue bien mais c'est pas
terrible terrible pas me prendre et cdc
vers s'arrête pas souvent car elle
pendant ce temps copains qui viennent le
7 contre nadal ça c'est inattendu faim
qu'ils disent est pas encore là car
c'est troisième set 5-4 40-15 reiss est
chaud je pensais qu'ils savaient faire
trois sets ça donnait ou là mais donc
coué premier revenu à temps mais voilà
moins ils accusent cinq secondes d'avoir
quoiqu'à voyage 7 kg 5 km h un qui
pouvait prendre angers 4 à 20.30
ouf j'ai rien dit puisque du coup
surtout dans le premier multi adam g iii
avec matt imparable en g2 est donc là du
coup elle tour trois dames bien force
est déjà à 13 3 ces formats seront
prises en h3 dam des trois échelons
d'ailleurs il pouvait prendre le pouls
c4 est ce qu'il peut faire d'alger 3
d'un match 4 dames français yaris
traitement ses studios à faire enfin
style offerte à tout re 590 300 m2 ouais
je pense que le mien le plus pratique
c'est en au faux pas de la santa pièce
de plus c'est fini ouais c'est fini here
is a huge france 8
ouais enfin lancé moore passé mais moi
je la gagne ça là avec les noirs c'est
facile ça ouais ça fait 2 0 mais une
partie qui est un peu été tronquée
quoique le damel froid était déjà été
déjà une petite erreur quand même au
delà des bonnes équipes mais bon c'est
beaucoup il n'a perdu au moins une
minute trente
mais le vendre ils étaient déjà plus
très bien à un moment il s'est
déconnecté ouais mais une minute trente
c'est beaucoup oui oui c'est sûr que ça
rique oui il est il a un visage pas très
suis pas conre il est dans la vraie vie
mais il a l'air d'être un peu dégoûté en
fait fin pas dégoûté mais genre il en
mode
ouais je fais des trucs mais alors après
bon c'est très dur pour moi de les
joueurs chinois il part très très mal
anglais ce qui fait que alors un mec
comme dean lien il a l'air très sympa
très vraiment dingler marrant ouais mais
comme tu peux pas vraiment communiquer
avec lui c'est très dur de te faire en
habit précis quoi ils parlent vraiment
aussi mal anglais que ça malgré tout les
voyages qu'ils font et tout ça ils ont
il parle un peu mieux que les autres
mais je crois que de mémoire la salle
qui parlent anglais correctement et puis
là ça dure encore s'améliorer ces
uniformes et extra dû s'améliorer parce
qu'elle est partie faire ses études en
angleterre c'est ça c'est ça
bon ben il va bien parler maintenant
mais elle a toujours bien de parme est
un mets donc par exemple promus ils
prendraient mal an de l'est li chao
voilà li chao celui qui parlait lui
enlevez lui fait beaucoup d' open dans
l'it shao en plus ouais voyage beaucoup
voilà donc t'as pas donc t'as jamais
trop comique avec ces joueurs là donc
ces décès des personnes que tu connais
pas vraiment tu les vois mais tu ouais
après encore une fois il a l'air très
sympa nding meiway est juste mais la
barrière de la langue
faut le mettre au mandarin ça pète ça
passe ça va pas être évident et donc et
dong ding en tournoi mais ce que quand
tu joues contre lui tu vois un peu plus
joyeux quand même où il va parce que là
sur la carre vraiment les une tête genre
bah il a jeté ou à venir bah oui oui oui
pardon non il est pas où mais après il
ya une part de tension ligne barnes
[Musique]
après qu'il ait peut-être pas expressif
un tout simplement là ça aussi je n'ai
pas toujours et expressif je me suis pas
toujours non plus donc c'est pas
illogique
oui non mais là c'est donc on a un truc
qui alors c'est pas du tout une
sicilienne fermé au départ mais ça
commence à ressembler beaucoup et j'aime
bien la position de premier ce qu'on
voit là peu près 20 16
c'est plus simple d'ailleurs il
s'appelle lui-même prague quelque part
tu as any pragoise et se dit même lui
quand il doit malgré son pseudo sinon
c'est trop long par wes est comme moi
avec mgr j'ai pitié déjà en fait ouais
c'est plus facile plus court c'est bien
et du coup c'est un peu une marque en
plus pour aller mais là il roule ça
sonne pas si mal et ce qui est vraiment
une attaque pour les blancs ou pas c'est
un peu la question de l'âge investir
puissamment champions
j'ai compris toi ton truc c'est vraiment
de manger les pions quoi c'est
complètement différent
manger les pions ou en donner je peux
faire les deux as-tu fait les deux
savent que l égalité matérielle ne
t'intéresse pas non là je vois bien il
est gratuit et une gratuit c'est encore
meilleur
donc voilà ça c'est ma règle de base
victoire un très influent gratuit vous
me quoi tu le prends well as tu prends
l'option et après tout j'ai mis une
demi-seconde indien b4 hop là on dit
qu'il ya plus que 2 2 par de connexion
pour ruiz mince et wikis et qui a des
problèmes de connexion c'est génial
comme h à peu ce jour la connexion c'est
lui qui a d'ailleurs internet gagne
oracle c'est terrible j'ai pas trop
suivi le match précédent ainsi j'ai vu
qu'il y avait un match hyper
intéressante virunga et et martinez est
quand tu auras mais bon où était plus
fort mais je pense que le péruvien non
réfléchie et plus d'un est en fait plus
fort plus fort ouais plus fort mais
moins moins impérial qu'on aurait
imaginé franchement c'est ça il en
aurait fait plus dans le péruvien secret
est pas mauvais et pas un nouvel perdu à
l'aller 2 et r mais à l'aube d'un jour
d'hui alors que tu vois le match tahri
compte revendre forest franchement ils
m'ont pas ils m'ont pas impressionné les
deux ouais c'est paris c'est ça j'ai une
chance sur denain ses ventes forest
voilà ces vents de forest qui a gagné à
la dernière seconde dans la dernière
partie
j'ai dit qu'il était sorti du bois après
on fait des jeux de mots qu'on peu après
mais mais tu vas y mon panon les deux
franchement ils m'ont pas impressionné
non à prilly ce n'est pas mauvais je
vais connaître pas mal
les deux noms mais il est bien mais bon
oui c'est pas c'est pas l'élite mondiale
ça c'est clair non c'est pas un
potentiel n'évite mondiale mais tu sais
que quand tu compare le niveau de jeu
on va dire du top 15 20 mondial et que
tu mets sans relation avec le numéro 150
c mais c'est énorme la différence ouais
je sais bien je sais quand je les joue
les je rencontrais que c'est ouais mais
c'est ouest utah les différences dans
tous les compartiments du jeu de la
différence préparation qui est déjà
énorme
oui et en admettant qu'ils réussissent à
trouver une ligne où ils s'en sortent
puisque bon la préparation globale est
plus forte mais bon droit de se battre
aussi sur d'autres lignes
après en milieu de jeu ah non mais là et
là on blitz pareil c'est à dire que
quand vous jouez entre vous tu vas y
avait il y avait une tomate fonds ayant
bas mais en fait vous fait jamais
d'erreur quasiment genre vous jouez
pendant des heures il ya quasiment zéro
gaffe dès qu'il ya une gamme de toute
façon l'autre en profite face et hyper
rare qui est gaffe mutuelle cercle une
gaffe tu te fait punir tout de suite là
tu vois tu vois tu vois le match et
arrivant de forest enfin tu te fais ok
tu te fait punir mais tu te fais pas
punir direct ouais bah tu peux revenir
dans la partie et hier le match de marie
contrarie casse et voilà c'est moi je
crois que là dans les formats de choses
comme les d'éliminer trois faux pas
maintenant il faut parmi mes choix je
dénie tout moi c'est évidemment un way
d'un match au mans dans des matchs
serrés contre gries tous que c'était
serré ouais on aucun point
anaqua comme tu le disais avant le avant
le banc qu'on lance le live sur internet
il est bon ouais ouais c'est son format
est la 2d aussi peut-être fait pas si
sage ou wallace à jour mais je te dis il
est plus concentré plus focus alors
l'attendent à 8
j'aime pas je comprends pas pourquoi tu
jouerais pas payés sont là et j'ai pas
une impression que tu peux prendre
peut-être trois fois angers 6 à nantes à
tour pranger de que je voulais faire un
truc où tu vois tu prends trois fois tu
finis par faut prendre aussi surprendre
le caillage quatre dames h5 mais comme
yato pranger 2 tu t'en sors probablement
mais ces sports
je pense une dame habite le truc c'est
que ça crée pas vraiment de mélasse est
quand même là d'un défenseur
c'est pour ça que je suis un peu vieux
circonspect elle assure cavaliers au
sein qui veut faire d'un match 4
j'imagine
dommage 3-1 match trouvant c'est plus
sécurisant
tu proposes tu eu la même idée on est
juste meilleur casque mouais c'est un
plus non mais c'est déjà je jouais
gprenc 5 je suis pas sûr que jamais
cessé par ma tu protèges le fouet trois
cas une pièce qui peut être sous
pression puisque le cavalier g2 il peut
sauter tu protèges 5e 5t mieux place en
a je crois je suis d'accord avec toi
mais tu vois j'ai besoin de plus de
temps pour le voir
ça c'est vous bon mais là en fait prague
il a fait un peu n'importe quoi et que
dans ma vie tu as raison à ces robes
pressé c'est là aussi que tu vois la
différence c'est que je considère que je
suis le meilleur clairement pour ces
trucs là je considère que ba magnus et
finalement un bien meilleur mais tu vois
de 2008 ça m'a fait bondir quoi c'est
pour dire le niveau de magnus quoi ouais
c'est spécial alors ils disent qu'il est
22h30 en inde c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être alors je sais pas s'il en a un
autre à galan d'ailleurs on sait pas ça
parce qu'il est en france et a pas si
longtemps
ouais mais s'il a pas d'autres tournois
du retournement du système la rechute à
franges et 6 t3 g8
ouais il n'est pas trop tard pour
admettre ses torts sur le plan
provincial damas huit je crois que tu
récupères set j'ai un peu peur que tu te
prennes un dame s'est vite mais tu
accueilles 8e bon je sens que c'est
mieux pour les blancs meiway roger 8
c'est beaucoup quand même
donc comment est ce que les blancs
continuent la tacler 4 à la génie des
hommes prendre 2008
foot français 5 des français
cinq des six carriole c'est ici ouais
je voulais faire un brin de 6 mais ça
mange pas j'en comprends à chier c'est
puis tu dandine mais bon c'est un peu
too much to réussi j'ai pensé voir quand
on est dans le premier set et là pas de
choix alors je prends ces singes constat
qu'est 8 juste mais peut-être juste pour
f1 parfois faut pas se faire chier ait
eu à vienne juste toutes les pièces en
attaque et puis tu m'as enjoy gaming 8
ses huit médailles en même temps ça tu
peux commencer par daems et 8 puis touré
fin en soi sans la tour en effet elle
sera bien mais pour le monde travaillant
au sein qui tient la baraque
c'est ça voilà c'est pour ça que
j'aimais bien au g8 donc il faut que les
blancs il trouve et ce qui peut faire
fou prend ses cinq ici qu'est 8-10 même
sur foot français 5a qui a huit quand
même à oui moi je tends la vente avec
tours f1 excuse-moi gt gt pas suivi tu
m'as perdu quoi
et là tout répond je pense comme ça
t'évite lesquels il est quatre insurgés
pro match 5 par exemple kayak après
l'accueil f5 donc donc non pas j'ai pris
cinq ça c'était du mans sur kei 17,3
euros axa de batman ans et il ya eu 17
il tombe à la fin
non il n'avait plus de temps aux six un
peu biaisée de oui-oui 4,6 mais où ça
l'atout gagnant donc ça fait 3 0 3 0 3 0
on va dire pas facile parce que parce
que les partis ont été chaudes mais on
sent quand même le joueur chinois qui
maîtrisent largement les débats
ouais bah c'est pas une grosse surprise
mais ouais ça va être très dur après
encore une fois on verra ce que ça donne
au niveau des connexions aussi quoi mais
ouais je le vois pas retourner quand tu
démarres à 0,3 scellé tu peux avoir des
débuts assez on va dire difficile mais
bon normalement à ma troisième tu as
déjà réagi ouais tu commentes comment tu
gères d'ailleurs campagne il ya rarement
des matches comme ça en vaut échec c'est
souvent une ou deux parties contre le
même adversaire mais par exemple en ce
pitch est ce tu gères vraiment les les
séries discuter au tennis on dit que
quand tu perds trois points d'affilée
genre mentalement il se passe un truc
dangereux où tu peux tu vois ils disent
que trois points c'est le début d'un ça
peut être le début d'un mauvais roche et
donc comment tu fais pour pour gérer ça
dans des tournois d'échecs ou quoiqu'en
quand ça quand ça démarre mal
quant à un mauvais un mauvais passage
pendant le tournoi mouais c'est un vrai
sujet après une très dure à gérer quand
tu as un mauvais une mauvaise série vos
échecs en toi tu fais quoi tu essaies de
faire une ultime essai de de passer un
autre tournoi de limiter les dégâts août
à la rage est envie de marquer à tout
prix dépend des situations si tu sens
que rien ne marche et essaie de limiter
la casse si tu sens que tu peux refaire
des trucs on va dire tu vas essayer de
me dire tu as tu es tu te mets en un tu
laisses un peu passer l'orage peut-être
une partie et puis après tu t'en nos
charmantes ça devant et ça peut arriver
de surréagir de perdre un peu ça sa
lucidité dans ces cas là tu te dis ouais
je vais finir par en gagner une
tu vois un peu comme ça alors c'est pas
possible ça marche jamais ça devait
finir par marcher georges ou un truc
impulsif et non pas vraiment ça mais
peut-être commencé aussi à être
désintéressée par le tournoi surtout
plutôt passé sur suivant c'est ça le
gros danger serait donc de juste lâché
le tournoi c'est pour ça que l'idée de
faire quelques nus pour finir le temps
est passé à autre chose et pas forcément
idiote
ouais bah après aussi entend faire tout
genre deux fils tu viens de clients donc
j'ai mais qui veulent pas de fermer
l'eau s'il ya ce truc là dans l'est dans
les tours à faire mais de haut niveau
c'est que quand tu commences à perdre
tout le monde veut battre
après c'est normal ils sentent que t'es
pas en forme et ils veulent te unis
veulent en profiter quoi ouais dans une
petite question est ce qu'on peut faire
car les f4 ici pour jouer h 3 mai et h5
en fait je pense à cali g3 voulu toucher
3 et c'est la même chose que l on n a
pas le temps moi et ensuite tu auras je
crois pas que les projets 34 ans f4 vous
prendre quatre pôles sont bien trop
c'est pas mal et je pensais tu peux
juste alors sur france 2 ou 4 fois que
tu joues fauche 5 rouges et si c'est une
question de goût ça pour avoir le plus
en danger si ces jouets g5 g4 derrière
donc sur x h cinq cavaliers
qu'as-tu fait bouger si sûr qu'elle
prend tu fais je prends mais tu vas
jouer grand roque ici avec les noirs non
mais il choisit la troisième solution
tu peux tu peux faire les deux fois
besoin que c'est pas mal d'ailleurs
aussi donc à temps il se fait des pions
vous plaît sur la colonne est fois ils
se gagnent la case de 4 même pas que la
cado 4 en fait c'est aussi tout un
phénomène nous l'a par exemple il avait
d'ailleurs ça je comprends pas qu'il
n'ait pas joué je pense que c'était
juste qui peut changer 5 à 4 et jouer
avec grand roque après quand même vrai
enfin la grande quoi souvenant l2 tu
dois changer quatre dernières ou altran
a été bien moi c'est terrible ce qui l'a
fait petit rat que je n'ai pas du tout
at encore 4 comprendre cette épreuve
sept défaites sans doute pas moins bien
le monde f3 cas y revient puis toujours
pays
détroit le cavalier blanc tu as
peut-être
à troyes d'ailleurs en d2 peut-être un
peu plus d'avenir en a 3 puisque tu peux
revenir via ses deux tu joues rouges et
paquets 4.5 et prendre cet acte iii fc
sky à 3 donc il a joué autour des 8
mais là c'est pareil voilà faut prendre
si sky id3 maintenant de tête comme
tapage wave 3 tu vas me mettre l'autre
cavaliers en f3 donc tu as jeté higdon
et là tu es un peu mieux avec les blancs
clermont battu à pouvoir tu vas pouvoir
tourner et jouer contre le pion des cinq
très isolé et jouer à la structure le 4
contre 3 et c'est un peu une question
intéressante de doc péage dans le chat
qui demandent si vous avez des prêts
peur des préparateur mental dans avant
les tournois dans le top10 connaît pas
la règle générale
ouais c'est un point qui a été je pense
négligé par pas mal qui est intéressant
je pense on fait un qui mérite de s'y
pencher donc je suis en train de tester
des trucs
voilà c'est peux pas te dire je pense
que ça va donner mais je suis en train
de tester et tu t'es si ce n'est pas
indiscret un tu t'es rapprocher d'un
coach sportif
20 coach mental pour ce portier we can
oui je sais ce que j'ai à dire le coach
mental voilà sportif c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille déjà avec d'autres athlètes de
haut niveau
ouais ça sera intéressant si si par la
suite eu pour dans quelques mois ou
voire quelques années parce que c'est
s'est jamais du court terme et faire un
topo sur ce que tu as travaillé ça peut
être hyper intéressant ouais bah ouais
je verrai déjà ce que ça donne jusqu'à
près aussi il faut que ça il faut que ça
se passe bien aussi je pense que enfin
c'est ce genre de truc tu peux pas tu
peux pas prévoir ce que ça va donner
comme résultat
[Musique]
meiway à mon sens c'est une démarche
intéressante en tout cas à faire et un
diététicien je crois que j'en avais déjà
parlé mais tu as déjà bossé avec un
diététicien
ouais alors passez pour le couple
spécifiquement pour pour un régime
spécial échec mais ouais y'a des fêtes
tous et comme dans tous les sports en
fait il ya des gens je pense aux
cyclistes mais qui s'est
professionnalisé à fond voilà aussi dans
le labo en s'asseyant note un autre
sujet mais tu vois pour les pour des
gains
[Musique]
tu vois sur la masse musculaire sur ce
que tu ingère et que c'était assure des
entraînements voilà bah c'est comme dans
tous les sports alors aux échecs c'est
peut-être un peu plus difficile de nous
trouver l'entraînement parfait mais bon
prince et comme dans les autres sports
ça va dépendre du joueur aussi donc
après c'est peut-être aussi plus
compliqué parce qu'il ya moins de il ya
moins de joueurs d'échecs qui ont
utilisé des dés et compliqué ce que aux
échecs oui tu peux faire des parties
d'entraînement mais ce sera jamais
départi de compétition bon pareil au
tennis mais au tennis tu peux tu peux
voir un résultat on va dire tenterait
mon coup droit mon service et c'est bon
je dis pas aux échecs aussi tu peux
ressentir un résultat mais au cyclisme
tu vas voir ton temps sur ton ascension
oui et tu vas tu vas voir tu es nouveau
tenté nouvelle longueur aux échecs
whittall a pendant que ça ne parte à
rien tester quoi c'est ça que tu veux
dire c'est que ça c'est assez calme à
l'étape a du bon alors je vais je veux
poser dire tabac tue ton ce quart oppose
à leur âge parce que ça ça ça veut rien
dire mais tu n'as pas ta pas de référent
qui permet de vraiment voir si c'était
plus performant
tu as trouvé des nouvelles idées quoi
c'est surtout ça qui est le plus
important au g3 cet homme a duré 5
alors surtout reproche 3 il veut faire
quoi bah je tenais ce fait vous la main
cet ol-om un kevin pas mais moi je me
fais pas la main attention hein
karaté prend des 5 bah oui ouais mais
bon assez dur quoi ces combinaisons de
coups un à vous êtes dur avec moi tu
adores mais simple complète
attends attends j'ai perdu la position
j'ai perdu ma position je suis sauvé par
un bug la foulée sein de cette f4 c6r
prendrait cinq attaques de tours h6
voilà on est pas on n'est pas on n'est
pas allé aussi loin mais c'est que
vladim il me fait le truc en fait il me
fait répondre à des questions qui
pensent auquel je peux répondre quand on
commente ensemble mais qui sont pas trop
facile non plus pour pouvoir me
reprendre si jamais je me trompe et
m'engueuler en fait c'est insupportable
donc la 4c bien joué mais j'ai 4 6 4
c'est bien non tu bloques tout est là
après tu peux décider avec les blancs
soit tu joues purger cinq soit tu joues
en f3 soit tu joues kenya 3 groupes la
sueur pour acheter j'ai l'impression que
tu vas devoir lever 30 sur quelles
épreuves faire pour pranger 4 et 5
c'est risqué fou prendre qu'un cran j'ai
peur que tout reprendre et 4 ça fasse
nul en fait je suis pas certain
le roi par vert revenant non mais tu
joueras f1 de l'atuge ou kf5 un truc du
genre est complètement bloquée et dans
mettons quand j'ai quatre peut-être n'en
rouages de tatouage 4 c'est mérité et
fallait jouer
3 je pense l'accueil f5 cette fois le
roi le roi blanc tu penses que le var
peuvent même gagner ça alors kf5 av3k
vallée h4 quelque chose comme ça bah f3
n'ont pas donné la dame mais dommage
d'un match 3 2 kg 3 et sur wade 3f
cinglante à peut-être encore un des
quatre d'andigné j'ai passé les gens
très mauvais pressentiment sur cette
position
avare en plus il est mal autant noël
mais là tu damage 3-2 a aussi des 4
alors il faudrait avoir coltiner 7
ac pour prendre le roi rebrousse poil
mais ça va vous voyez vous comme moi
pour l'instant c'est très bon signe pour
lui tu penses tu penses qu'il est favori
du speech est ce un nom c'est phil
rogers en boulettes duras voilà je
rajoute des cadres du coup monsieur
leroi arrivant des quatre je vois pas le
mal tu sais ce que tu avais c'est ce que
tu avais dit moi je dis [ __ ] mais
c'est 8 mais tu n as rien là tu peux mon
jeu de dames a trop payé fin mai va
peut-être là perdent finalement bah
ouais dû courir après c'était en temps
mais là des quatre c4
valliot 3 une prison étroite et en plus
il a plus de temps et il n'a pas une
bonne connexion et l'ars oi oi oi oeuvre
ces deux dames f5 sétois fini un effet
repris affaire d'âme pendant récents
taperont 5
là ils poussent les pions à elle c'est
pas facile à jouer en fait ouais métal
pions décalage au caire aux biens ou la
dame de du coup il n'est plus la
pression sur 24 ils sont marqués il y
avait plus de connexion - le mans pour
points 3 il ya plus de connexions ouais
c'est terrible
la connexion la connexion à jouer alors
en faveur du joueur indien on attend
l'arrivée je pense qu'il avait des
quatre le kg 3 d'un mètre 5 février sur
fric pas trouvé le match 3 des classes
mais je pense qu'il existe juste pas
ouais il a il n'y avait rien on le roi
il est parti et ouais près d'alger
sainte dame justice mais c'est trop long
tu te prends cahier f1
du coup il n'a pas réussi à et aussi
maintenant tu dalm 4 parce que prise
pris trois c4 massage est vu par exemple
et puis moi de me casser le premier
coquette j'ai pensé la wii ça marchait
pas non inclus
keyyo call du coup voilà
enfin john callas au 4 juin sky c'est
simple il y aussi ce genre prise
présence et 4 dames ses huit bons trades
b5 encore mais là ça devient vraiment
dur de croire que tu vas t'en sortir pas
du coup il a laissé il a laissé
s'échapper
du coup le premier train pour prague
donc on est amis à mi-chemin 5 + 1
maxime il reste encore 42 minutes de jeu
et il ya trois écoutes je pense que pour
l'indien vu les problèmes de connexion
de oui il faut essayer de tenir au
maximum jusqu'au bullet et puis après
c'est eric ont dû l'être
la connexion fasse la différence quoi
ouais compter sur internet fou ouais bah
non mais pas forcément mais il ya il ya
des trucs à faire quoi
alors 7 7 7 7 ouvertures tampon squale
avec avec les noirs c'est dantec fou des
cinq là ou là j'ai compris mon nom mais
ça c'est une offensive pour les blancs
tu prends le cwatup rendu fou ouais ou
moins furent donc là les pièces c'est
changer on va avoir la dame des cinq
dames des 5 cl d'eau donnent des cinq
petits rôles d'hommes b5
du coup sûr dame ces deux dames c4
legalis tranquillement fait avec les
noirs ouais puis même tu peux avoir des
idées en buts ce qui me donne des
positions égal mais où c'est un peu
chiant à jouer
là je sais pas est facile et cote à la
demande des cinq arrestations faut pas
échangé on est d'accord avec les blancs
voient la limite si si tu avais à quatre
en tout cas de la tap à 80 étages et
dames g4 ici tu fais quoi h5 dame g34
d'alger 4 nages 3g 3g tuèrent que tonton
h3 il est très dangereux
tu cherches les problèmes - oui je
cherche tout le temps les problèmes de
cette façon tu as joué mais bon le pion
à je crois dans ça et qu'il est
dangereux mais c'était pour essayer
d'amener 4-2 d'empêcher le développement
du foie fuite fait il a fait un macadam
des 5 et est il faut prendre nul
madame de cinq chefs pas pourquoi tu
joues pas flouer 7 en fait à nam ces
deux voilà je suis un peu perdu une
finlande ap ces deux symboles coach pour
jouer au 4 x 3 mais c'est limite un peu
mon bien excellence dames certaines
j'aime pailladins de pétrole pourra
jouer soit fou c'est sainte foy tour de
8,9 pouces est simple tu vois pour eux m
dames c4 maintenant il est peut-être c4
faut qu'ils fassent 40 sur d'un bébé
trois fous en pâte chimique j'ai envie
de dire à long terme cette pollution de
l'air grave pour les noirs rapport au
coût de 4 noir mais l'amendement parce
qu'après dam des trois tu perds du temps
d'ailleurs t9 au conseil l'elysée avec
les noirs je fais quoi tu fais damas six
ouais mais maintenant que quatre autour
des 1 tu vois tes
active ou c4 coupé deux terrains
d'auxerre déjà maman d'un des cinq là
sur ces 4 il veut faire dame prend b3
ray ouais mais tu as toujours bien
n'achète pas autour des 1 à tours bien
c'est toi var ou trois fois trop paris
va prendre en b3 j'imagine ouais donc il
a fuit l'a fait mettre le plus en ces
cas sûrement pour éviter la structure c3
b4
j'imagine mais il va quand même se
manger une tour en a6 un fou en d2 le
tourin ça va être un peu chiant non
ouais c'est un peu pénible et a pas
vraiment le temps de faire tourbe et
huit tours prend b3 si je ne m'abuse une
question si loin de 7,3 c'est trop mais
c'est jean roy 17 tours à 6,3 ces sept
cas 3,17 et attendait la foulée de
rosser cette fausse à y avoir des
problèmes mais c'est mérité
j'ai pas aimé la séquence et surtout ses
5 4 x 3 nature un peu pressés sur le
pion à et sur 24 ans assise ça va être
bien ouais
à 6 on ne peut pas juste faire flamber
de la même si si c'est ce que je fais
mais vous et 2f six tours à 4 way déjà
laissé sur un truc avec tours but on
prend des 3 après par la suite well jour
en trois sets vous taurin tomber 8 pour
prendre prend b3 ça m'a l'air de tenir
un four b2 ouais non ça a l'air de tenir
fermement gp mis toute la séquence
je pense que ce que j'ai payé mais c'est
de fait que tu avais pas dans ce genre
de position tu dois jamais ressentir le
besoin de bégayer pour faire nul n'a tu
vas réussir à faire nul en sifflotant
c'est même pas ça c'est tu dois tu dois
avoir l'adversaire qui demande la nulle
part c'est ton objectif normalement
quand à cette position c'est que ton
adversaire se disent ouais faut pas
laisser la partie du lemboulas par
exemple autour des 3 5 ou aussi wells a
commencé à être très désagréable parce
que t'as pas le temps de faire fouet
cette tour des huit qui achètent cette
emprise ouais mais tu as peut-être
devoir faire cette fois ci tu fais ici
c'est tour et tours a des seins ça va
être pénible un ouais grave on n'en est
petit ce tour bien fou aux 7 à tour
d'essai tour des huit ouais ouais ça
tient encore tati encore de justesse que
sur tours 17 ya tourné juste montrer et
le truc c'est que si on prend 2,7 il
prétendait
du coup les blancs vont pas réussir à ce
que tu fais tour des huit ça va non pour
les noix 5 maintenant attention
d'ailleurs tous les 2e 5e on est là tous
rangs des 8 et le néant trois
commandements c'est pas pour bigpoint f1
il va faire coiffer retour d'élie 3e 2
nuls hockey lnah tu prends à 5 ont
poussé un maintenant je pense que c'est
dangereux
localisé à cinq n'a pas peur de mettre
ton foot on pions sur noir dont tu
mettras le fourbe et quatre au pire de
toute façon ouais t'as aussi à 4,1 dont
on comprend à caton prendre ton bébé
c'est ce qui va diriger la france
non il ya foy où là les twittos caisse
et plus
russeil donc il veut faire à quatre
prochains mois bah écoute ça a l'air
d'aller un bon il n'en mulhouse
maintenant il faut qu'il a joué six ou
sept pour des usa est à jamais et a
jamais possibilité de faire les tours
j'ai trois tours h3 et compagnie pour
attaquer les pions parce qu'il fera foi
fuite au pire et défendra g7
moi même j'ai une foi dans cette
situation j'avais joué georges et 6 3 3h
saint-ours g 3g sont que j'étais très
content mais oui vous fixé très bien il
me lhbib l'inde tout et je me rappelle
d'une partie où final mon adversaire m'a
taclé pierrick saint thomas je les
pousse et depuis j'ai gagné était chiant
en fait elle a prêté pions ils ont plein
d'espacé était était bien quoi des fois
fuite
les blindes brad et amicale
bon ça c'est nul à ou attendre ces deux
jeux fera trois peut-être
ouais ben oui nous dérober à 2 froid je
voyais food & cie
elle a calculé 5 commencé à chauffer je
crois qu'il ya eu 5 encore mais bon t'as
pas eu ta pas eu le temps de calculer
jusqu'au bout
ouais je sais pas ça m'aurait intéressé
mais oui oui m'a pas l'air il va pas
l'air il m'a l'air d'être un peu en
dedans non web après c'est déjà il y
avait des problèmes de connexion parce
que je veux enfin après c'est sûr que
avec toi qui aide aux commentaires on
sent on sent que c'est plus facile tu
vois on voit on voit les erreurs plus
vite mais c'est plus facile aux
commentaires que en jour ouais mais j'ai
l'impression que il le laisse quand même
tu vois c'est pas à ce parti la mousse
qui fait spécialement c'est pas à ce
paris uniquement bien attention ces 5
parce que quand même que ça c'est une
position qu'on attendrait pas qu'ils
aient à la cie jouer c'est simple je
pense qu'il était mieux voilà ils lèvent
flégeau ces cinq écrits en gros danger
tombé six juges à leroy est complètement
coupée on voit toutes les pièces sont
coupées c'est terrible là je vais jouer
je vais pousser leurs ceintures pas fan
on n'a pas envie de faire juger 5 h 5
commencer bassi où j'ai 6 7 5
ça c'est top parce que demain tu vas
prendre quatre tours fc est sur toi tu
peut déjà prendre 4 surtout reprend tour
bien tomber uytsel mange pas de pain ou
le matin il est deux secondes à elles
seules preuves en fait il a plus de
temps mais il sait cette prime ou
vainement une prime ou parents que c'est
terrible ça il a utilisé
il a utilisé du temps là il n'a pas joué
tour un bon là ça marche encore sur roya
point il ya trois ans l'une s'échauffent
je sais pas trop comment de là bas je
pensais à la gagne et où il ya plus de
connexions ah bah voilà
en tout cas sa prescience à hilard goyer
a récupéré la connexion la bombe et 4,4
me répond j'ai quatre ans fermé c'est
chaud j'adore ouais je vous vois il va
prendre trois
ouais ouais j'ai cinq noms wager 4 voilà
la magnifique cette somme partie j'adore
aller ça envoie voilà il ya aussi à
faire nul
ah non un nom pas nue bon mais là ça
doit être nul mais bon y'a plus de temps
quoi les connexions wi fi connection bas
il s'est bien battu 1 3 2 ouais ouais
faut voir si la connexion continue à
être un problème récurrent ça peut ça
peut changer la donne l'impression de
prague à régler les problèmes de
connexion qu'il a pu avoir
ouais alors que oui non mais oui qui
esquisse un sourire après avoir perdu en
fait il ne sourit que quand il perd
ouais comme tout le monde sans péril on
triomphe sans gloire
oui me la gloire mais l'a32 faut quand
même qu'il fasse très attention parce
que si sa connexion reste un problème le
petit la gare de pas mal joué en
ambulance il a pas l'air d'être mauvais
dans les dents les escarres emblème et
que la connexion ne s'est pas un si gros
problème en simple puis chez un humain
et une peluche une vrai nom mais c'est
ça peut ça peut ça peut ça peut être un
vrai problème
ouais ça peut être un vrai problème
donc cette petite petrov fixette petrov
là vous êtes
vous êtes vraiment fort à haut niveau
dedans parce qu'il ya tellement de
choses à savoir dans cette vente avec
cavaliers c3 des princes et rois c'est
d'une complexité ont joué ça il ya
longtemps qu'on avait pas au monde
qu'ils le jouent et c'était c'était bien
c'est terrible dans le sens où tu as des
nuances de partout c'est hyper compliqué
bon alors robe et un tour des huit dames
c'est un nom qui est pas un c'est une
question et moi là par exemple j'aime
bien les blancs tu vois mes mais bon moi
tu me demanderais je suis allée blanc
sont mieux je mette la dame en f4
foucher pages à taxer set et je vais un
peu attaquées droit mais toi tu évalues
ça commence truc là bien pour les marges
je sens que je suis nul tu vois non mais
dans le sens où des tueurs finale à
pâques site échange les dante quasiment
gagnant c'est juste ça ce que la
maintenance a g6 h5 quoi va échanger les
dames tapions h
c'est vrai mais berlin est un jeu bien
passé mais leur attention tu es
d'amsterdam 3 sets à 1 mais l'un dans le
coin de 4 je pense ça le truc est là
avec les blancs est ce que je peux jouer
sur un truc avec quatre 4 mois j'aurais
joué f4 f5 tu vois si j'y arrive je
serai bien f4 un belge un peu peur tu as
peur cela alors dit on décale
d'économies de 5 cet amas de jouer et on
prêt juste à me satan mais c'est très
lent je peux pas faire tout rejet 4 in
my head and prendre 5 points 5 mai
oui oui non mais ça va pour les blancs
l'amendement déjà tu as réussi des
doublés les pions tu as toujours les
dames donc c'est quand même pas mal
bref sadr ça devient équilibré d'après
toi roulé blanc même un peu mieux taclé
l'a6 à prendre de 4,7 sa gagnait du
genre à jouer aussi ça le système
prendre de 4,7 d'amener un tour
prendront lé tour des dames se comprend
on reprend et 2,8 d'olmes alors là du
coup est ce que si ça marche encore eu
peut-être moi je prends ces cinq puis
sept à huit c'est vrai et c'est vrai que
c'est un pion un taré c'était un peu les
mêmes structures que dans l'esclave
ouais mais là je sais pas parce que
toutes les finales toutes les finales de
tournois c'est plus du tout pareil
talent puis en c5 tu joues la russie
soit le plan c 5 il est fort après tu
fais des 4 à 4 et tu t'avances quoi au
nom il a mal négocié la pose de wailly
et dames g5 qui sait ce que ça peut être
un coup dam des trois rois c'est un fils
en fait c'est sa promesse obligé de
revenir palmarès a servi à rien pour
gêner je suis pas fan aussi parce que
cette paille position au tchad tout ça
sans réussir une attaque de man
donc un jour plus tôt la position
athènes n'a juste aussi dans ces cas-là
si son ami chip passionne la finale de
tournoi si le pion à jeu va super vite
du jour où s est ensuite acheté un f4
par contre ça peut être un bon coup
si tu arrives à faire f 5 on tour des 3
j'imagine dames deux dames des cinq pour
ac2 nom voit ses deux tours bien et là
je sens quelque 5 peut-être donc
étonnant ils vont envoyer le pion passé
voilà voilà l'info voire même d'être aux
échecs oreilles par la finale elle a
quand même une bonne tête non la brigade
on peut pas faire je voulais faire et
fils mehdi minne keeper des problèmes
avec des échecs
bah déjà il ya tourné un kimono ce pays
qui voient ça j'avais pas vu ce tuer
c'est chiant tu sur ton bien tu peux pas
prendre rien puisque dame prendre un
prise ronchon h4 et leurs ouailles pas
dans le carré non nés dans le rectangle
ça va pas mais peut-être qu'on peut
jouer
qu'est-ce que je peux faire f 6 tours d
un roi ces deux matches que j'aurais
cross est nommé là ok tu pourras omis
d'y rendre la vie moins bien quoi
ouais le plus rage et 3 vous trop avancé
non l'ac thann 4 tab à 4 tours d1a les
jouets si c'était cher trop naïve de
recettes devant fait je pensais ah oui
non mesdames katurian cd est du coup et
ça ça c'est ça ces trucs dont on parlait
en fait autour d un roi à ces deux temps
on va me croire 4 ouais c'est ça et
c'est ce dont parlait mais c'est plutôt
bien pour les noirs ça non bah ouais le
pion h est quand même très avancées et a
pas de contre eux avec les blancs enfin
parce que tu veux il y réfléchit à quoi
damas quatre échecs intermédiaire des
maquettes
je suis content d'être là pour prendre
du coup tu gagnais à 2 ouais ouais moi
j'étais parti sur comment ça non mais tu
as et se sait ce que tu avais proposé en
première c'est bien ça tu fais je crois
d'alger 2 h 2 h 1 ouais les temps les
plus simples ouais toujours osé chacun
aux gens mais les échecs fait c'est ça
qui est frustrant c'est que c'est hyper
compliqué et hyper simple en même temps
j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque fois les
coups tu dis que tu aurais pu les
trouver dans orwell apprête à l'ecoute a
les idées dernière aussi un façon à
chaque position d'un stock limité de
cause je veux dire bon c'est je vais
même pas de parler des cartes couler
gotha trois ou quatre candidats
oui cela ne met plus la loire que tu
puisses ne pas
sidéré ça peut arriver à cujus tu vas
pas considérer le coup mais normalement
même bateau nombreux je suis va
considérer le bon coup je vais
considérer quasiment systématiquement et
mais juste après le peu avant le
comprendre faut comprendre la 9-5
adresse un cas chacun non mais ce qui
est frustrant c'est qu'en fait une fois
que tu le vois le bon coup une fois
contre la montre et une fois qu'il a vu
à la maison et que tu vois l'idée c'est
à chaque fois tu as quand même
l'impression que tu aurais pu le
comprendre par toi même c'est ça qui est
frustrant
ouais c'est bien mais ouais après tout
aurait pu le comprendre mais bon parfois
c'est pousser quand même parfois oui oui
pourquoi pas dès lors rien de caché
aussi c'est là souvent il n'y ait pas eu
dans la partie mais de dix coups qui
justifie tout le concept
oui oui je la connais alors là celle-là
je tenais bien des premiers cinq ici
pour les noirs j'ai jou ça depuis que
j'ai 14 ans je les neiges je pense
honnêtement que c'est moi qui ai lancé
la mode 2d progrès 5
ouais bah tu es à prague à lembeye ne
suit pas la mode pour enfants quoi dsk
est ce que quand tu vois que quand tu as
lancé là ne la mode ils n'étaient pas
nés 6,6 à 2005 non celui-ci met au fond
pas claire mais de toute façon c'est pas
ce moment là que j'ai vraiment lancé la
mode c'est plus tard de 1005 personnes
changent âge était pas encore 2005
c'était comme la nôtre et les modes
c'était était déjà grand maître non
ouais et
les mecs je suive pas les modes de tous
les grands maîtres heureusement oui non
je crois que ça c'est bien lancée en
2013 un truc du genre
c'est vrai que parfois de penser
kidnapping quoi c'est pas non plus le
truc 12 niveaux
oui mais voilà delajoux moi même moi je
la joue un moment je tenais tout mes
partiels tandis que j'étais pas un
influenceur sur instagram en 2005 encore
d'un instagram d'ailleurs johnston vrai
mais je pourrais pas m'appeler influents
sont battus mais tu postes souvent ou
pas je suis pas d'ailleurs faut que je
te follow mvl chef bador je te faut le
tout de suite que les gens fassent
pareil que moi car on le fout nous tous
nbc qui on te suivent tous alors attends
je suis en train de champion de chercher
non je suis plutôt des filles de girls
sur instagram
on a tous notre faiblesse
bien sûr bien sûr c'est un seuil c'est
vrai que koul power je gagne je suis tu
as ton petit message bas en tout cas
tant à gagner un temps tu viens d'en
regagner un d'ailleurs saturn en gagner
deux c'est déjà ça c'est déjà ça et je
te mets des temps je te mets des laïcs
sur tes photos non 3 3 ben tu vois ça
commence un maintient une position
achète une position d'échec en fischer
vendôme tut entraîné avec carrick
richner c'était très heureux c'était
quand ça mais c'était à brest on ne joue
pas au 23 mai a été la bomba écoute
juste avant vous êtes une escalade avec
jules dents mais sur mes côtes bretonnes
n'en a pas réussi à casser la gueule il
à ces nouveaux tapas énormément de
photos encore ouais j'en ai quelques-uns
je crois que je vais commencer en 2010
est un truc du genre
je l'utilisais jamais au jeu british
toujours pas énorme mais et utilise les
filtrer tous déjà à j'ai commencé j'en
ai un
ça y est tout est rentré dans game mais
je crois que tu as tu as bien ta table
et une quinzaine de personnes 1 qui ont
qui ont paulo ça a l'air sympa là ce que
tu as mangé
ah ouais abbas a dit elle la suit well
as et mes petits poulpes et ses toiles
influence art en fait ouais c'est beau
c'est vous du coup cette position
profitons savoir pour les blancs enfin
un peu mieux au moins en pratique quoi
mais bon qui sait qu'être c'est
peut-être bien joué du coup c'est
peut-être plus mieux 1 tipsa jamais
vraiment été mieux place du coup faut
peut-être jouer des cinq en fait je
prends qu'il prendra me prendre et tout
les idées et la question c'est est-ce
que tu continues à pousser un peu genre
toujours tout repenser 4 après l'idée
c'est que tu peux pas jouer pour ces
mythes le tour prend ses limites d'un
premier trotter profite si tu joues tour
des huit tours c'est cette impression
prendre lifewave 6 pour prendre 17 faut
prendre mes deux tours est bien oula ça
j'ai pas vu en hausse
ça perd pas tout de suite mais juste oui
tu peux jouer d'un bébé 5 en fait voilà
c'est ça ta b 5 tours france et quatre
nuls dans le prendre mes propres entendu
plutôt dans le prince ekale j'ai envie
de dire je dois prendre mes deux
peut-être tu crains un truc de nulle
part
bah déjà ta tour bien aidé à me prend
7,4 mais là je pensais prise prise tour
des 8 1 tu dois tu dois tir et annule à
une petite nul c'est toujours bien il
joue déjà la montre why i joue la montre
d'ailleurs on en est où là c'est une
heure et demie c'est ça il reste 15
minutes de saint ouen saint ouais c'est
ça et il ya quatre heures il ya 4 buts à
2 moi je pense que c'est la bande
dernièrement 5 + 1 ça dépend comment
elle finit pas sûr non mais ils font pas
des lieux rapidement mais logiquement
oui ça doit être l'avant dernière mais
ça peut se jouer à un poil de pas grand
chose quand il faut et fils
et puis aussi avec leurs connexions je
pense que tu vois cinq plus un c'est pas
c'est pas de dix minutes plus les
seconds net un peu de latence de machin
de way en plus il fait b3 rénover ses
gammes un petit plus pour les blancs
corps non tout petit nom à main ça c'est
le microscopique n'ont même pas rien
j'ai parce que je t'accorde bon je
t'accorde en bonis symbolique
en fait il n'existe pas mais dans ton
esprit il existe ouais mais je le
rencontre il y avait beaucoup de choses
qui existent dans mon esprit mais mais
je fais pas mais pas plus loin quoi on
remarque à près de damas un ça commence
à être un peu plus que ça j'aime panama
cinq ans ferme et pourquoi je peux pas
te faire tour 17 pour essayer de te
faire pousser 5 ou 10 ans est descendu
pour 17 tu voulais faire b5
je pensais à 4 en fait moi je voulais
juste qu'il me dire que la dame à saint
qui était mal placé mais mesdames des
cinq à tour des huit quand même parce
que tu as le fou qui qui regarde et je
peux pas tenté dame cc6 d'un point à 2
au moins 128 ans
voilà tu dors là ya pas de points
gratuits c'est vrai ce tour paris vii
moi ça me va c'est fou c'est simple
surtout il faut c'est ça
plus même et là je peux pas faire un
coup comme non sa b4 en fait je voulais
faire mais je crois pas que ça marche
les quatre tours promener cette dame
prend 17 6 ans gratuit
quant à deux ou en b 4 je surfe ou c5 ya
tout lieu d'un merkel
4 j'étais sûr qu'il y avait une case ah
ah ah c'est pas facile
nantes a raison il ya rien mais là je
suis moins convaincu puisque le
tâtonnement à saintes qui est quand même
très mal placé famille à ce satané pion
à 2 way a déconseillé dans toutes les
écoles c'est tour c2a en fait j'ai 4
voilà voilà un bon coup enfin oui oui
mais en plus tu sais tout à fait
envisager maintenant je voulais pas je
voulais pas t'exciter trop vite mais là
tu es tu aurais dû lâcher 4 je pense
qu'il ya des émoticônes g4 dans le tchat
là c'est évident voilà les gens ils
écrivent des g4 dans le tchat
ouais je le vois je les vois ça ils sont
là quoi et ils sont là avec deux points
d'exclamation toujours g4 ouais c'est
attend toujours est très heureux alors
est-ce que je vais réussir à en envoyer
il faut il faut il faut que tu sembles
la chaîne bitstream à nez je crois qu'on
m'avait offert un abonnement mais je
suis plus y est valable à tout le monde
doit être abonné la chaîne bitstream
c'est ouais bah ouais enfin surtout toi
parce que tu fous en fait tu as toujours
l'objectif des 300 se poursuivre en fait
c'est ce que ça génial
ah oui ça va oui et oui et on en est où
maintenant on n'est qu'à 200 somme ça va
l'espoir hamon y arrivera un jour ou
l'autre on pourra surtout des tournois
après ouais pour réclamer plus de 300
bref après sera 400-500 là et c'est vrai
que tu joues beaucoup de tournois
ouais alors attend un petit adam des
deux là non plus d'ailleurs c'est pas
c'est pas bitstream en fait pour ça
cette chose comme un ferment la maison
mais ça s'en va on connaît exprimé pour
avoir les motifs de dégâts peut-être un
petit maxime d'ailleurs qui va bientôt
apparaître alors à temps et tu pourras
faire des vlad aussi et ça ça peut te
avant on avait des carpates chef aussi
mais ce terrible non mais ça va prendre
trop de temps à remplir un formulaire et
au moulin mais c'est terrifiant va en
france à une autre fois peut-être que
quelqu'un te t'offre la bonne et on ne
sait pas si terrible
les bayardistes le petit libye aussi
tally vita le slip est ce aussi le sipes
way qui a un rapport avec robert s mais
ses fils et un sifflet ouais il y avait
une petite tête de gym avec racing était
tous un peu c'est vrai cette année kevin
qui font le chat ouais nan t'as pas mal
de mecs t'as pas mal de trucs tape à la
pomme encore tape à la pomme bon alors
cette partie ça s'anime un peu il ya un
pion de plus maintenant tu vas être
content tu doit préférer les noirs non
ben tiens plus pions gratuit là des
petits risi tu as aussi mais je suis pas
sûr que tu connais ce résultat where is
it à ça mais si bien sûr que si je
connaisse et c'est l'espagnol bhagwan
his ou faria patricia fou p2i maintenant
j'ai pas vu le temps aussi sa prise est
fou de dégâts il ya tous rêvent 7,3 de
cette fuite de 5 c'est bizarre il a fait
5 c est plus de temps en fait ouais mais
là il va se prendre un petit geste fou
des six pouces à la f4 h6 assez cruel il
va la perdre en est peut-être surpris en
prenant pas la perdre
je fais pas faire tourcoing f4 et c'est
encore les questions de temps donc c'est
pas fini et puis tour f1 sur est solide
parce que si j'ai c'est de toute façon
tu m'as tu bats toi un b3 ça peut se
jouer à pas grand-chose cette partie ne
soit pas là peut-être jouer qui ça peut
sur la connexion edge of vermilion bay a
perdu ouais c'est dommage il n'était pas
loin et ça ils pouvaient recoller au
score tu es pouvoir monter à 4 3 ouais
ouais c'est dommage que la du coup il
retourne à -3 et sa braise et d'orages
thaïlande suit les au-dessus voyez quand
même mais moins que ce que j'aurais pu
penser waimes après aussi la connexion
fausse naturel encore ces deux bah ouais
enfin sa peau sa fausse mais il domine
pas non plus sur l'échiquier je suis
d'accord sapho simple le score peut-être
qu'ils auraient aimé tu ailles appiah tu
te sens pas assez impressionnant que
braga mandat parce que oui c'est quand
même un passé quand même un client quoi
ouais ouais mais je sens maintenant là
il est déconnecté encore je prends à
l'angevine un ponton à 3 jeu conceptuel
veut faire b 4 non bêtement moi mais
j'aime pas fou g7 des quatre français
trois tout moment ça je suis tu
tellement pragmatique parfois jambes et
quel jeu joue key c6 des princes et ça
nous prend ses 3 qu'est-ce qui fait pour
ben ouais by the bay 4-1 mais je sais
pas j'y crois pas c'est un peu spécial
et toute façon tu sais que des cats et
de la marne g46 beaucoup bah oui ça
c'est voilà c'est l'école c'est l'école
de batterie tombe et qu'elle j'aime pas
je comprends pas c'est pas mon école des
échecs dans mon école du jeu non mais
c'est un peu c'est un peu spécial j'ai
perdu pas mal de parties comme ça en
jouant
c'est fait c'est marrant visuellement
mais ça fait pas grand chose en réalité
généralement voilà d'ailleurs non mais
ça va encore mais ça c'est pas si je
suis pas convaincu quoi je comprends
mais qu'elle tu sais quel point ces cinq
qu'il est tellement bien pour empêcher
les d4 bah oui et file est mieux qu'un
pion a en fait à échanger de pioncer
contre le pion à en réalité quand après
un bep cap sinon est ce que le chat est
prête pour la finale de ligue des
champions dames 1 est ce que le chat est
pour liverpool
j'imagine toi tu es pour liverpool ou
tottenham plutôt tottenham après j'aime
bien les deux équipes mais donc moi je
serai pas malheureux qui gagne en plus
liverpool le mérite je pense mais est-ce
que ça a un rapport avec le fait qu'ils
aient eu goris aux cages atonale quand
tu sais bien ce que je pensais il ya un
lyonnais dans le truc ça y est ouais
enfin c'est parti là après moi j'adore
ce qu'a fait pschitt ya aussi l'équipe
non mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
assez impressionnant ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont réussi à faire cette année en
ligue des champions après c'est un peu
triste pour l'ajax
sinon quel ouais c'est que l'ajax il
aurait quand même été fou ses 16 ans
ouais c'est fou parce qu'il n'ya pas a
finalement les équipes qu'on n'attendait
plus ont toutes été éliminées
ouais ouais il ya eu des surprises de
partout il ya eu des émotions aussi quoi
il ya eu le petit la petite est de type
mb quand il quand il ya eu la var et
tout allait mieux qu'une série netflix
j'ai l'impression causés chaque n'y a
pas énormément surpris une saison plus
le niveau en ce moment c'est terrible
les séries netflix
ouais bah better cole sol c'est ça fait
ça fait une plombe qui est passée
d'épisodes y a rien en ce moment ouais
c'est ça et puis niveau
non non non rien rien rien tu d'accord
avec toi mais tu t'es ça y est tu te
regarde un peu les animés japonais ou
pas
à l'époque ouais j'en ai regardé 2 3
mais pas des masses tu peux essayer
death note hébergeurs par l'impro à la
en fait des notes je connais j'ai lu
tout le manque d' amélie hébert york
tu connais ah non ça je connais pas tu
peux tenter mendes matinale fantastique
elle note le manga est au dessus du pas
de l'animé c'est le problème en fait
quand après la nuit mais tu es très bien
fait mais c'est vrai que quand à lui le
truc là mais rien que le scénario
extraordinaire mais c'est la whey pierre
mobile j'ai entendu ça vient de sortir
sa non armés ça vient de sortir mais ces
patients la crise donc donc j'ai que
j'ai que gekko netflix
bon heureusement la partie c'est un peu
mieux pour prague un peu mieux pour
prague il va faire cavalier 400 prendre
option à vii et aux fous et finalement
tu as eu raison les pions des essais y
dominent et 2000 les pions a et b
quelque part ouais ouais c'est ça et
donc quoi way pour les séries évidemment
il ya quelques séries pas malienne
quelques s'ériger en attente mais c'est
vrai que cette patientèle puisque la
session tous en phase i télé en ce
moment il y avait quelques séries saint
passionnel fixe une fois le talent puis
c'est le catalogue
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu de
mal à se renouveler bon parfois tu as
des petites séries sympa i sorte j'ai
fait shooter j'ai fait un bodyguard
j'ai fait aussi deux trois conneries
ensemble en fait tous mais dans
l'ensemble moi il n'y a pas de asyl aux
arnaques qui était pas mal
la série sur les losers au sport ça
c'est pas vu ça ah ouais ça c'est pas
mal bon j'espère tu auras jamais
d'épisodes sur moi ça va pour le bourg
on t'as qu'à une belle carrière là mais
2017 tu sais à la non qualifiés mais non
mais c'était des jets plus il y avait
des épisodes sur du curling
des trucs sympas là un truc de chiens de
traîneaux aussi rien tu vois et ses 12
heures mais ça qu'on fait pas des vrais
loser quoi c'est réputa prend un peu
c'était un peu des athlètes de sports
ouais c'est pas forcément très
médiatique qua non d'un mec qui était
j'ai fait des essais pour joindre bien
et puis qui était pas assez sérieux qui
a bug parisienne pour jouer en nba qui
s'est retrouvé dans l'équivalent des
globetrotters
voilà ce que je vois pas mal
ouais alors demandé 12 heures 12 heures
quoi voilà donc one on s'était vraiment
vraiment une bonne surprise et ud acéré
sur sunderland aussi quitté pas mal non
c'est dommage il s'était tout de suite
non confirmé mais c'était pas mal mais
du coup vu qu'on parle de séries tout ça
pour essayer de faire un parallèle avec
avec avec tes tournoi est ce que tu fais
ce que tu regarde des séries pendant tes
tournoi fait le soir tu rentres de table
un petit robot oui tout le temps mais
alors après sa dépense et si j'ai une
série en cours je l'aurais bien sinon je
peux regarder aussi des vieux trucs ça
dépend mais ouais j'y passe pas mal de
temps
donc tu files à partir de là f1 on m'en
a parlé après je suis pas un fan de
formule 1 tous
ouais mais je sais qu'on a parlé je vais
jeter un oeil quand même mais du coup tu
tu rentres bon tu le matin tu te lèves
tu fais quoi tu te lèves tu te prépares
tu ça se passe comment j'ai battu
l'allemagne alors déjà banane est temps
que tu joues à 15 heures on va dire tu
joues à 15h tu te laves ac alors là non
bon alors à part aux us où je me lève un
peu plus tôt mais même pas parce qu'en
jouant très simple parce que j'ai le
décalage horaire dans la gueule
généralement je me lève entre 9 et 10 à
en jouer au petit déj
ou alors petit déj dans la chambre ça
dépend si j'ai des trucs sympas ensuite
après c'est très variable mais bon ouais
généralement c'est repos enfin ça va
être serré où il ya roland garros ça va
être roland garros na qui a calmement
réparé en fait bas généralement la
preuve est faite bon votre dire je vais
regarder des deux trois trucs ils sont
pas encore prêts bon normalement j'ai
reçu des fichiers à vérifier et je vais
vérifier justement lénine revoir légumes
que j'ai que j'ai à à revoir trois
quarts d'heure avant d'aller à la partie
et remet donc ça c'est tu fais vraiment
avant quoi en fait le matin et tout tu
t'es tranquille où es tu rentres dans ta
partie j'aurais une heure avant ouais
bah c'est pour la révision des lignes
surtout après il faut mais faut que tout
est décidé avant enfin un tout ait été
décidée la veille qu'est ce que je vais
jouer et sert à ça tu décides le soir
ouais c'est ça peut arriver d'être en
panne il avoir un qui est un truc qui
est une nouvelle idée qui met à mal
l'idée que je voulais jouer etc
mais ouais de manière générale et tpr
est pas tu tombe souvent dedans ou pas
quand je m'en rappelle ouais ça quand
même ça arrive ainsi pas toujours parce
que c'est pas si facile évidemment les
mecs lui aussi même quand tu tentes dans
l'après patetta pas toujours c'est
souvent des trucs ou totale des
positions un peu jouable mais pas pas
des gros avantages maintenant oui mais
j'imagine bien les mecs en face c'est
pas des peintres un ouais on demandait
ce que tu as une équipe comme carl scène
ou pas en tant que tel j'ai eu des gens
qui ont bossé pour moi c'est rien enfin
mme etienne le maître principal mais pas
encore en tant que tel évidemment là ça
dépend aussi comment ça se passe pour
les grands prix fidh et c'est assez
clair s'il ya des coups de boost à
donner je vais me faire quoi et ici je
suis enfin c'est pas si sûr jeunes
qualifiés aux candidats désolé vous
l'avez entendu ici en premier donc quand
je veux me qualifier aux candidats là ça
va être une autre histoire
et évidemment tu peux nous lâcher aucun
nom barris tienne oui mais
à etienne c'est bien comme non tu nous
lâche un nom quoi voilà c'est déjà pas
mal non prend on prend on prend ce qu'on
à quoi voilà ce qu'on a méridienne donc
c'est pas ça n'est pas vrai secret non
non ce n'est pas un secret en tutu s'est
pas tabou c'est pas tabou mais mais du
coup donc en fait c'est un peu c'est un
peu comme nilsen pour karl scène
vlad pour great chouk toi ta petite et d
autres non c'est à dire que carson quand
on bosse bon après tu as une scène ta
fraise quoi des mails principaux qui
sont connus pour karzaï mais dans l bon
après ça on a su par la suite que double
fait bosser pour personne pendant le
chantier du hms
d'ailleurs j'avais deviné on aurait dit
que c'était pas possible puisque les
chefs lui qui m'a dit c'était pas
possible peut-être ce que on m'avait dit
que 1 mais c'était toi je crois parce
que tu m'as dit que moi j'ai dit ça
possible tu m'avais dit que dubaï était
pote idol qui ne met pas mal mais c'est
possible mais pépé toi parce que enfin
ça c'était l'argument qu'on m'avait
sorti mais c'est pas c'est pas moi qui
les ya trois c'est peut-être quelqu'un
qui m'a entendu dire ça et qui te l'a
dit total mais mais en fait il se trouve
que ouais mais il se trouve que ce qui
est marrant c'est que j'en ai parlé avec
vlad il ya une semaine et il pense que
si manu s'était mis à bien joué c'était
parce qu uniquement parce qu'il est
tragique double offre
j'adorais ce extraordinaire et le point
qui pourront enfin normalement pour
preuve on en a on s'est perdu en route
la après non mais double d'hésiter
vraiment intéressant de moi mais on les
ouvertures
ouais il est bon dans les ouvertures du
boeuf
ouais mais il a un peu trop chez pavla
diddy qui peu trop copié nepomniachi
c'est pour ça qu'ils percevaient pas je
serai pas là il m'a dit copie trop
nepomniachi dans sa manière de jouer
là je sais pas là c'est trop spécifique
pour moi mais vannes oc est très bon là
il a fait des trucs pas mal pour pour
sacha ouais nan mais il est bien pour
les ouvertures juste il est il est mieux
pour pour préparer que pour jouer
glad ah bah oui ça en fait c'est pas ma
carrière de joueur est passé on s'est
tous ces peuples non mais même quand il
jouait en fait je pense qu'il est bien
dans les ouvertures et dont il a jamais
joué
enfin il l'a pas utilisé les ses
meilleures années les a mal utilisé un
jeu ou bien utilisez tout dépend oui
mais je pense qu'il sera enfin il les a
mal utilisé dans le sens où il va pas
pour les échecs oui clairement ouais ça
bon après je veux dire c'est des choix
de vie moi je comprends complètement
weave a eu bien sûr bien sûr c'est
souvent quand t'es pas content et pathé
à tous quoi tard et a du mal à
comprendre de leicester dit oui pourquoi
il gâche son talent ou quoi mais d'entre
eux telmex il a une vie aussi peut-être
que tu as et enfin monde est d'accord là
dessus est ce que tu veux faire une
petite pause de trois minutes
bon il coûte non c'est bien la boulette
ok ok moi et en tant que telle à c'est
c1 c'est un bonheur absolu d'avoir un
maxime c'est hyper intéressant de
discuter avec toi et je pense que les
gens sont très heureux on va essayer de
voir un petit peu si on peut on peut
récupérer des questions on va aussi en
profiter pour leur demander s'ils aiment
bien le le rythme qu'on utilise pour
suivre la partie il est parti
aujourd'hui dans le sens où on profite
on profite de t'avoir pour un peu moins
regarder quoi le match et web on en
apprécie le mal devient chaud là il ya
que deux points d'écart ans est pas oui
non bien sûr bien sûr mais je veux dire
par là que on va dire que quand je
regarde seul ou que je regarde avec
regret que sébastien joie ou quoi on est
vraiment focus sur les parties si tu
veux là on en profite pour voir là avec
toi d'échec d'un paul général ou et puis
après on web en passant c'est il faut
aussi voilà ces jeux légers pas très
bien fait là j'ai pas du tout repéré le
moment critique
en fait il était tout le temps un peu
mieux avec les blancs et puis un moment
ça s'est décanté mais sérieux qu en
général si je vois un moment critique
dans la partie je vais que tu te tais tu
crois pas été là quand elle était un
genre de chat voilà
souvent tu sais pas ce que j'ai mis les
gens sont un peu et quand est ce que
j'ai mis une petite une petite page
depuis maps quand on met des 200 pages
de pub n'y a pas de lézard sallanches
il s'est laissé des sables qui les ont
passés ça c'est ça voilà c'est ça tu
connaissais tu sais que tu peux utiliser
l'application twitch d'ailleurs sur ta
chaîne pour pour passer les pubs
directement de ton téléphone savent
qu'avec ton téléphone il ya une option
pour pour envoyer les pubs ce qui est
plus pratique quand tu stream que
d'avoir à changer c'est de naviguer sur
ton ordi tu peux mettre l'appli twitch
sur ton mobile lg l'appeler switching et
tu sais mettre les pubs avec ton mobile
ça j'ai jamais essayé mais en fait ouais
après ouais moi c'est pas trop mon truc
mais je sais que c'est pas trop son truc
non plus le set sur sa chaîne youtube tu
m'as pas de pub non je n'ai pas pu voilà
c'est pas je pense pas que c'est le bon
format alors en plus sur la chaîne
youtube j'ai envie de dire à deux
bloqueurs fin fin de l'année ouais c'est
pas faux mais voilà après bref juste par
rapport à tous oui il faut pas abuser de
toutes façons de faim c'est bien aussi
d'avoir des pubs de la monétisation mais
c'est pas un de ses poèmes chansons pour
moi
en fait là pour pour la peine ce si
important pour twitch parce qu'il n'y a
pas que nous qui gagnons de l'argent
quand on met des plus qu'en fait c'est
aussi la plateforme et quand ils
essayent de pousser les échecs à fond
tout fait un gros boulot un pour les
échecs
ouais en mettant des premières du var
des premières pages tout j'ai vu ça
ouais je voulais pas rajouter mais tu
vas bien tu verras une première page en
français j'espère qu'en anglais tu voir
la première page ce serait super cool
ouais ça ce serait cool j la première
page en france à s'être senti tout de
suite quoi j'ai tout de suite à 1500
2000 2005 ont voyagé quel mental 2005
quelque chose comme ça arriver à la
première page ça ça fait ça fait tout de
suite tout de suite la diff et n'oublie
pas quand à la première page de demander
des photos faute faut plus plus le
demandez pas ce que tu as beaucoup plus
de gens de passage et s'il faut l'opa en
fait il retombe pas sur toi donc faut
plus dire ouais j'ai pas encore
fo faut que tu te fasses des post it ou
tu te fasses des post it et ouais t'as
chaîne youtube aussi que j'ai vu je
serai bien que de mettre des liens et ce
cas quelqu'un dans le le chat qui peut
nous y vont ils vont nous mettre les
liens trinquette par n'a pas besoin de
se fatiguer normalement ils sont des
petits liens de la chaîne tweet chaîne
youtube de maxime normalement que je
crois que la chaîne youtube le monde
enfin c'est le lieu compte que j'avais
du coup là il y aurait là pas encore
actualisé même peu importe si bas les
vidéos sont là et du coup et ludwig de
large utilisation
ouais tu prévois des vidéos spécifiques
pour youtube ou des rip les salaires des
petites vidéos qui vont sortir alors pas
c'est pas moi ce sera pas moi en train
de commenter mais des trucs de deux
tournois quoi ouais moi c'est pas mal je
disais tu as le petit ludovic de lâches
qui est dans le chat c'est lui qui avait
fait la miniature de la vidéo qu'on est
sorti quand de sueur sur la demande d
montana elle qui a les douches de
lingerie ouais ok on était très heureux
de cette miniature l'artiste photoshop
ouais ben ali leïla c'est lui qui a
trouvé l'idée tout franchement ça m'a
bien fait marrer d'heure je te l'avais
envoyé sur facebook ce que j'étais
tellement mort de rire ouais c'est
peut-être bien marrant était pas mal et
bien pas mal fait
donc on nous dit dans le chatt cofiroute
jeanne des monceaux voiliers mais je
pense que phil rogers démontre à tout le
monde puisque angoula qui est juste
supérieur et ouais et ce qu'il a gagné à
blanc-mesnil d'ailleurs j'ai pu voir ça
passait dans le baril à remonter maxime
il a gagné leur mobile dont un peu par
miracle ce qu'il avait perdu la première
et du coup suite il joue alberto david
en finale j'imagine qu'il a gagné
mediapad crée des formes crème vous
demande si laurent voit encore avec karl
scène je crois oui bien au contraire
oui c'est pas encore fait virer il n'y a
pas de raison d'ailleurs fait plutôt du
bon boulot face au temps qui sera
champion du monde je pense pas qu'il
change trop son équipe n'ont pour le
moment ça marche tellement bien
ouais puis une bonne alchimie entre eux
hein je le sais j'ai j'ai pu voir ça en
direct
donc ouais puylaurens est content je
pense que magnus est content ouais donc
forcément ça va ça va continuer mais
mike magnus tu penses que c'est vrai les
rumeurs genre comme quoi s'il perd le
titre qui pourra arrêter les échecs
ouais ça c'est sa soeur qui en avait
parlé
oui c'est pas impossible
tu sais jamais comment les mecs
réagissent parce que ce serait ce serait
dommage pour la peine qu'il arrête les
échecs à 6 mouais
ah bah oui mais après faut que ce soit
moi qui le met à la retraite
ça serait pas mal mais c'est un match
difficile pour toi non match si tu joues
pour pour le titre bah je pense que pour
tout le monde c'est difficile prendre ma
fille non clairement clairement mais je
veux dire c'est pas le sait pas le style
qui te convient le mieux mais enfin bon
dans mon approche est très différent car
en match de beaucoup plus de travail de
fond dans les ouvertures
tu as des différentes
c'est très différent au niveau de la
mentalité pour avoir une mentalité
tournoi d'ailleurs on avait bien vu que
je fais également les crânes pop aussi
de compte par jacques car il avait
galéré che galéré mais même contre
caruana au final il allie pas il a
galéré wa il a gagné la somme et galérer
quand même ouais parce que si la partie
dans la douane mais on dit il vraiment
si ici et sauf cas sur al ce chic offre
via une occase
non mais c'est surtout je pense que ça
il avait mal joué dans la première
partie
oui la première partie il était paraît
il était complètement gagnant ah oui
dans la première vague et je dois dire
que même même moins tu vois je regardais
sans ordi puisque jamais regardé sans
ordi j'avais trouvé le truc gagnant pour
les noirs ouais non
j'avais été très surpris killing pas
celle là en fait s'il s'était passé je
crois que 9e coup de la partie quand on
les joue chez plus à schiste ou quelque
chose comme ça j'avais annoncé tu
n'avais gagné la partie
du coup il m'avait rendu fou on n'y est
pas on n'est pas contre lui même si au
final je m'en foutais c'était juste pour
la prédiction et du coup est ce que tu
as ce truc là de dire ce serait sa dette
pour un joueur bon là on prend le cas à
karlsson caruana des plus pour carlson
ou pour caruana dans l'optique des
candidats ou dans l'optique d'un match
pour le titre ou tu t'en fous vraiment
en fait parce que c'est normal là pour
le coup je m'en fous après en plus
j'aime bien caruana en trente personnes
j'aime bien aussi mais minutes je
m'entends bien avec les deux donc
vraiment la gt gt neutral et quand il
s'agit de quelque chose ou t'es
peut-être plus impliqués comme les
grands prix là par exemple genre guiry
qui se fait éliminer au premier tour tu
dis tu es un cool il se fait éliminer ou
non je suis dit bon faut que je réussis
mon truc de mon côté et puis avec déjà
folle réussissent le truc de mon côté en
plus anichois c'est pas celui qui mena
impressionnant est plus dans ce format
et puis bon en plus à l'heure sarah du
mise énormément sur ces grands prix
fille est bon là c'est beaucoup plus
aléatoire mais je lis quand même
énormément sur la coupe du monde que
mine de rien l'année dernière tf1 ya
deux ans tu étais pas loin non mais j'ai
fait 2000 quarts demies en trois
éditions donc fait je crois que j'ai
plus régulier même si sydney rossi oui
puisque je l'éliminé encadrent suis bien
là peut-être le mec le plus régulier sur
ses formes
puis voilà en 2017
enfin en 2013 au cij avait éliminé du
gong d'ailleurs en 2017 j'avais éliminé
1 bat sasha
celui-là avant de perdre contre les
bonnes donc je pense que ouais ouais
c'est un bon c'est un bon sens rapport
que toi mais après il peut y avoir des
surprises à tout moment on se rappelle
de magnus cd&v éliminé par bout oui bien
sûr non mais c'est jamais facile mais je
pense qu'il ya ya de quoi faire je mets
mais en fait du coup le format des
grands prix ressemble beaucoup à la
coupe du monde
ouais c'est un peu différente avec en
bonus le système de points aussi
favorise énormément la gagnent la coupe
du monde tu as quand même la tension
nerveuse et avait trois semaines assez
plus long ça car un grand chelem
ouais c'est vraiment je veux dire la
coupe du monde je me rappelle pas de
jeans
généralement les demies la finale c'est
hyper erratique
la bomba est la mienne contre entre les
vannes en ont joué mal à la fin il ya eu
mais parce qu'aussi moi j'ai énormément
donné dans le match comme sacha mais la
finale elle n'était pas non plus d'un
très haut niveau en 2015 c'est encore
plus criant la finale et la finale car
yakine vide l'air c'est extraordinaire
ça j'étais belle sans plus si j'avais
éliminé 1 il joue aussi delà qui me
réussit pas mal en point qu'adversaire
donc tu l'avais déjà bien que tu es bien
cartonné dans stade vienne où j'ai plus
la menace était l'année d'après mais
c'était un match mais tu l'avais
cartonné mais c'était l'année d'après
c'était l'année d'après oui oui bah oui
mais du coup oui je n'avais pas les pas
compter oui mais oui mais bon si tu
réussis bien on nous demande ce que ce
que c'est que la coupe du monde bat la
coupe du monde c'est c'est une coupe
avec tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde
et les deux finalistes sont qualifiés
par là c'est un peu plus compliqué que
ça parce que c'est pas les 128 meilleur
tu vas voir des gens des pays un des
continents aussi genre l'afrique et on
peut représenter à des places aux siens
amérique du sud en asie bon même si bon
joueur mais tu as d'apatou qui vient
d'europe alors comment pourquoi que
c'est moins vrai qu'avant ça la majorité
des meilleurs joueurs viennent demain
mais bon je veux dire t'as pas 20 rue
score alors tu pourrais très bien avoir
l'image
oui on a pas mal barré voilà des joueurs
africains il s'en fout car si mal nantes
à bassam et joue pas mal évidemment 2007
mais sinon bon c'est pas d'ensemble est
mais t'as pas de tapas d'élite hamon mg
on espère avec par exemple l'apparition
du temps dans abidjan ça peut développer
des vocations un peu c'était bien ça
m'est donc assez la coupe du monde alors
pour en revenir à la partie un peu
puisqu'on en a pas du tout parlé qu'il
leur reste dix secondes puisque la cdu
trois prix chine ça va plus vite donc
prague avait sacrifié un pion dans
l'ouverture
donc pour ce genre de compensation en
fait il a emprunté le fond des cinq là
il veut absolument empêcher ces 4 il
veut prendre que j'ai donnant willaey de
oui j'ai pas fait gaffe il pouvait pas
prendre g2 y avait un air tran elle
assure ainsi c'est quoi le projet 5
comprend des simples et bien il est mis
autant et il faut que why i fasse guère
puisque la connexion n'est encore à
trois barques way 3 barça veut pas
forcément dire que tu es ça ça veut dire
que tu as des petites déconnexions
intempestives tu peux avoir des petites
des connexions web sert qu'à tout moment
tient fou c'est ça que c'est élégant way
est là surtout prend 1,6 d'apprendre des
quêtes le gagner du coup donc les noirs
sont gagnants
non non c'est pas gagné encore suite à
des petits problèmes techniques ça le
foot et catherine latour g6 et mal placé
enfin il serait bien placé mais elle est
mal placée encore d'autres après ça peut
jouer autant que trois secondes 9 de la
foux des quatre jeux
des canons certaines franges et rav4 il
assure des triplés mais il fait un
réseau de maths
ouais c'est pas mal joué ça en pratique
en tout cas l'aja qui décale détroit et
la tour c'est rohff ou voir tu attends
tri qu'il a maintenant au tour c'est
trop à tour ces deux à tours c2c fort
aussi faire un échec qui va prendre à
deux hélas les blancs six mois ça va
faire 5-4 à l'étonnant fin je suis
vraiment étonné de la performance du
petit à l'origine est sévère quand même
when we le redesign je m'y attendais pas
leur cercle
c'est ce qui se passe c'est que c'est
sans doute pendant trois ans tu joues à
5 ton dessin tu t'en fous tu joues à
quatre projets 5 à 3 et ensuite tu vas
jouer tout et donne un paraguay
donc ça méniennes mais bon c'est bizarre
de reason ah ouais aussi moi j'avais
déjà une question et par rapport aux
suisses au suisse candidat x est ce que
est ce que c'est ça c'est tu penses le
l'option la plus dure le tournoi est
intéressant l'idée intéressante mais
c'est mal foutu dans le sens où tu dois
pas avoir une seule place pour un
tournoi comme ça pour moi ça perd tout
de suite vachement d'intérêt par exemple
de jeu c'est beaucoup trop random ça
s'ajoute un calendrier déjà démentiel
donc il est fort possible que je ne joue
pas sa dépendance à ce que tu joues pas
le way a carrément tient méthodes ruiz
l'attend ouais senti tilt
non mais je reste et c'est pas autorisé
sa à la méthode riche juge dans le
peloton presse et ses caves embêtant que
de faire une remise à ce niveau là mais
j'en ai je pas mal à une époque
je me rappelle je les joies contre les
éditions de frites genre 5,32 ou des
conneries peut-être cette afrique ici
souffrent x at on a gagné quelques
usines comme ça tu sais un moment l'ordi
joutes des cinq qui jouait 5 que tu
joues f5 puis à leucate et puis voilà
j'étais très fier de moi mais mais c'est
pour des échecs bassam et favorise quoi
on lui demande ce que je fais je
comprends pas trop la question du rhode
island commence on était partis contre
nac a de manière générale par rapport au
personnage et son style mais je
comprends pas trop la question je sais
pas si tu peux faire une réponse si toi
tu l'a comprend déjà et si oui si tu
peux répondre du coup enfin quand on dit
non mais on a des parties intéressantes
après par rapport aux personnages à
hilla il n'y a toujours été un peu
grande gueule mais bon ça c'est pas un
crime
donc après un plus illogique de toujours
d'obtenir des positions un peu combative
et noir montant partisans ne pas
toujours en partie dans mes preuves
souvent quand on est les parties sont
intéressantes donc chine une question
aussi sur le manga mli soit c'est un
cannois 3a niçois par être exact voilà
donc tu sais bien que moi j'imagine
auteurs enfin je sois scénarii soit un
truc du genre je me dis si je me trouve
qu'il fait ça aussi en collaboration
avec gagne je n'en sais pas beaucoup
plus de toi hein c'est juste comme ça a
eu lieu juste à côté de chez moi quand
ils ont fait la présentation pendant le
festival j'ai juste lu et du coup oui
mais voilà sur internet
j'en sais pas plus que ça va ça va oui
ça peut être que sympa de façon ça peut
que faire parler des échecs ça peut être
laissé au site populariser un peu mieux
au japon en fait au japon c'est le shogi
qui est à la place numéro 1 un super jeu
le shogi d'ailleurs mais du coup je
guidais ce serait d'essayer de
développer développer également les
échecs au japon au final les meilleurs
joueurs d'échecs au jeu pensant les
meilleurs joueurs de shogi puisque il
1 d'ailleurs la passerelle pour fait le
choquer un jeu beaucoup plus compliqué
sur certains points que les échecs qui
fait que c'est plus facile d'atteindre
un bon niveau aux échecs cochenille
ouais c'est plus facile de passer du
shoegaze échec des échecs au chaud dit
ouais c'est ça mais toi tu aurais tu es
super bon je pense au chaud dit parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de calculs au chaud
dit ouais c'est dur quand même vraiment
m'a déjà crs pic le ça pique
tu sais quand les mecs de bonnes tour de
handicap qui est la pièce de loin la
plus forte au shopping et puis en fait
c'est rien points alors bon pour être
franc c'est une tournée indique comme
c'est pas du tout le tour d'andy kapp
aux échecs ce que bon pour résumer les
règles du show mais en fait quand tu
prends une pièce adverse tu la récupère
tu peux la parachuter ensuite sur
l'échiquier
enfin sur le sur le showman peut-être
s'appelle chez pas sur une petite chose
comme ça ou schumann plan porterait et
la pointe c'est que comme tu peux
rajouter les pièces n'a pas la stratégie
d'échanger les pièces
ah oui donc ok si tu as une tour de plus
et comme aux échecs c'est une tour de
plus mais qui avait toujours autant de
pièces sur l'échiquier du coup deux fois
là je comprends donc en fait une tour je
crois que c'est l'équivalent d'un pion
ce qui fait que évidemment du coup de
messages avait pas tout de suite compris
ouais du coup c'est pas ma tête
et oui il ya des gens qui disent et du
crédit hausse un peu mais après la fête
les pièces sont beaucoup moins puissante
qu'aux échecs [ __ ] à tout un phénomène
de promotion quand tu arrives sur les
trois dernières rangées adverse
voilà et du coup tu es bon ou pas moi
j'avais compris deux trois trucs après
je suis pas très bon il ya une nissan
qui joue pas mal
yannick pelletier aussi ici et me donc
quoi après faut travailler quoi pour
être mangés à la fin tu m'as dit heureux
de la théorique c'est pareil c'est
courageux c'est en fait toute la théorie
ce la théorie principale salle c'est sur
la position du roi parce que le plus
important c'est de construire en fait je
sais plus si je crois qu'ils appellent
semble enfin c'est un château alors je
sais qu'ici ça s'appelle toujours en
japonais mais en fait qui décède et
pièce tu places les clients et les
pièces de façon à ce que le roi puisse
s'échapper en cas d'attaqué tu sais
quand les pièces de comment ça se
parachuter atci pas de faire réseauter
en gros voilà donc bon revenons à la
partie vite fait alors qui est mieux
c'est les blancs non by viennent de
prendre l'option b 6
c'est gratuit c'est pas gratuit adams et
7 c'est bien joué ça puisque dame
pranger prend est en fait à tout
reprendre 3 qui suit ouais parce que le
pion g2 et cloud et saas est terrible
c'est sans doute foutu derrière tours 7
saddam et dorion marée noire trois
points
pourtant dans l'es17 pour f2 kiev 6 pour
prendre prendre des huit la panique
me cattoir ou là à tour f8 il ya peu
d'âme s'étrangle dames 4 c par match
joué dans satyam plongée 2 je crains ni
un petit domaine deux rouages de pia
patour f4 qu'est un catho france 3 et
france 3 qui t'ont pourquoi je crois
direct et toi tu calcules à tout
reprendre le sable et 25
nathan s'est pas encore fait parce qu'il
ya des menaces de partout il n'ya pas
cavalier f6 tour des ça va tomber autant
sa tombe cinq partout gros problèmes de
connexion ouais ça c'est sûr que la
connexion et impactante dans ce match
maxime est bon ils résistent bien mais
bon il sait jouer un oui non mais
l'impression qu'on désigne un large
succès nantais qui s'arrime et google
qui ont commencé à tenter une partie en
fait ça au bout ça m'a marqué en fait il
avait les pions sur la deuxième rangée
ils ont mis les toutes les pièces sur la
troisième rangée
ils ont joué comme ça ouais maintenant
le problème de fond c'est si tu mets
tout le tracé sur la troisième manche
était cueilli à froid j'ai cinq échecs
et mat annonce qui en fait oui ils ont
mis les pieds sur la troisième rangée
mais ils ont changé donc qu'ils avaient
des fois en d3 les cavagnan f3 je peux
comment ils se débrouillaient pour kylie
faisait un genre de fisher random sur la
troisième rangée
ouais j'sais pas exactement et donc
ensuite ils ont essayé le quai à angers
1-1 et cavagnan g8
ils ont recommencé quand ils m'ont
mondiale et jeter un coup d'oeil en fait
je crois mais je suis leur a mis la
pression
ouais j'sais pas ils sont dix n'en fait
n'importe quoi mais après c'est dingue
quand il pense comme ancien de leur jeu
je crois ils ont ils ont que 13 ans 14
ans et hyper jeunes
wen qui pense c'est fou quoi c'est
vraiment des enfants c'est même pas des
vrais oui c'est des ados mais à peine
ouais bah oui non mais clairement bon
après ça devient de plus en plus jeune
je suis je me sens pas petit la nature
commande tu commences à être un papy sur
le circuit ovale au top
et encore je suis entre guillemets
relativement même dans le sens où j'ai
pas à jouer les gros tournois avant 2015
donc tassées nouveau sur le circuit
quand même encore dans ce sens là mais
bon ça fait quatre ans que je voulais
même tournoi avec tout le monde que je
joue tous les grandes chaînes thouars ça
c'est terrible
j'aime pas du tout lé le format tapas et
de variétés la serbie là ils ont passé
de dix à douze joueurs
le problème ça valse avec les douze même
langue donc ça veut dire que même toi
parce que nous en tant que spectateur je
t'assure que ça nous frustre vraiment de
voir un énième mv elle n'a qu'à tout âge
et enfin on adore voir jouer ensemble
ouais ça frise tout le monde ça frustre
les joueurs ça frustre le public
vraiment loin des spéciales quoi de
l'affrontement mais en fait ouais moi je
dis toujours que si c'était un tableau
ce serait beaucoup mieux parce que tu
vois des nadal djokovic ou t'es content
parce que tu en vois pas beaucoup eu une
tableau c'est que c'est vrai que c'est
un peu dur dans le sens où bon après
faut de réponse a déjà heureux parce que
t'as pas assez d'argent pour te
permettre de faire un tableau d'avoir
des mecs qui vont arriver monte à un
tournoi dans l'année comme ça c'est la
coupe du monde mais tu peux pas avoir
chaque tournoi qui va avoir un million
le prize money et bombes pour les mecs
tu vois faire les valises tu sais pas
quand tu rentres tu dois faire et visa
etc
non mais il pourrait y avoir au moins
seize joueurs tu vois ça pourrait faire
un petit tableau
ouais de 12 à 16 à mon avis ça doit être
jouables quand même oui bien sûr mais en
fait ils pourraient faire faire c'est un
truc auquel je pense depuis longtemps et
non mais tu pourrais faire des trucs je
pense depuis longtemps et clé vous savez
c'est encore une autre idée une autre
idée
en fait quand je bosse à la fij aurait
proposé de faire un truc j'ai bossé pas
longtemps mais je pensais que j'avais
une idée assez brillante assez
intéressante c'était de faire des side
event comme ont comme au tennis en fête
où il joue en double c'est à dire de le
faire un event d'échec 960 ou en even de
beats à 4 ou un event de faire un ou
deux event à côté où tu pourrais avoir
un prize money qui permettrait à
peut-être des joueurs de se tua de se
spécialiser ou quoi oui oui bien sûr et
je suis sûr que ça pourrait prendre en
fait ouais non mais c'est clair qu'il ya
pas mal de trucs à faire bon alors après
aussi bien un truc est en croissance et
que les échecs deuxième plus populaire
m'en a pas mal d'endroits donc comme mon
avis ayant un train de pas rater de ce
point de vue là mais avec internet en
plus les échecs c'est vrai ça convient
vraiment bien aux retransmissions
internet
bon et du coût d'un million ms il est
malin enfin je sais pas j'ai un prix de
sa voix lors peut-être il n est pas mal
mais bon il est l'hôte résister puis on
sait comment ça va se finir il va perdre
autant mais je me demande s'il est pas
super tard chez lui parce qu'en chine 6
et 7 heures de décalage en chine
donc ça veut dire qu il était 3h du mat
ouais et est en réalité on dit il ya
ceux qui ont l'habitude de se coucher à
3h du mat parce qu'il ya les matchs de
nba
oui et puis et puis gaouaoui qui doit
pas je suis pas la nba
en plus maintenant mais ce que lui lalem
biais toute façon pour lui ça et 8
heures du matin ça vous réveille et pour
qu'elles équipent leur n'diaye gpad
équipe en fait je suis moi je fonctionne
par joueur et puis par équipes de test
après il n'ya pas de temps d'étude pour
ça que je déteste bon après voilà là
j'aurais bien aimé wah wah milwaukee en
finale janice il fait un peu bulldozer
je suis pas trop laine vient donc tu
compte pas sur moi pour pour relever
mais mais continue enfin mais juste tu
vois si tu me parles de joueurs et que
tu m'interpelle à part curie et 3 4 mec
je suis perdu dans l'enclavé pour les
bucks ouais mais vite fais quoi moi mais
où là donc la dame n'doye fuite fou
cette dame f7 l'emploi schisme au
chiffrage 6 damev cette candidature
d'annecy 8 ou d'un bep vite
je ne sais pas vraiment mettez pas mieux
demain tu peux prendre la fuite toujours
dans le si ce n'était sans doute pas mes
écrits blanc foulée 5 un peu bizarre
parce que la voix d'hommes des six tu
veux avec les noirs tu veux roi f7
peut-être sept
et la fossette
c'est pas les noirs qui sont mieux
maintenant bah si c'est bien de plus
comment ça j'ai bien appris ça plante
plus pincus c'est gratuit c'est gratuit
ça faut que je m'en rappelle le 4 mai
mais oui j'aimerais évoquer la ilaha
illallah connexion il a la bonne
connexion ouais mais ça ça peut vite
repartir la conviction
la question c'est ce qu'ils pouvaient
louer ces quatre mais très dur à
calculer il veut faire nul mais là non
il vient de perdre une pièce alors
qu'elle a par me laurent f7 n'aurais je
sais pas bon finalement c'est enfin au
pays qui en gagne une au couteau et
c'est vrai qu'avoir quatre bars
d'internet on voit que ça fait quand
même la différence
c'est vrai que le match est un peu j'ai
pas envie de dire faussé parce que ça
lui d'avoir un bon internet aussi mais
c'est sûr cependant c'est un vrai
facteur
oui bah oui complètement assez italienne
c'est tellement populaire maintenant au
niveau
alors il reste combien de temps c'est un
peu la question que je me pose en 3 + 1
où il reste 36 minutes
c'est le début c'est le début et en
partie de 38 cents et donc oui est ce
que je me disais c'est que c'est vrai
que s'il tourne qu'à plus de +3 on voit
vraiment qu'on nous ait menti là où là
c'est gratuit ça non malheureusement je
promets main saf
je suis très heureux quand il ya des
pions gratuit mais oui vu vu le saas est
gratuit pas c'est gratuit
oui et donc comme on voit que la
connexion a vraiment un gros impact
c'est vrai qu'en un plus un ça peut ça
peut être un vrai problème pour
i donc il a intérêt quand même à faire
un petit écart et là c'est vrai que ces
deux victoires finalement coup sur coup
la lui font du bien oui
ah bah là c'était cadeau mais c'est un
beau cadeau
le chat a pu voir ma tête ce que j'étais
en train de me servir de faim ou de
boire mon choix c'est off un taf
tu as peut-être me rends même sur
internet
non tu sais ça va vite
ah oui mais j'ai échappé aux au même
après montbrillant tir tir abidjan au
foot
fait-elle digoin y avait une photo qui a
traîné un terrible ça traînait sur
twitter est-ce qu'on peut jouer ces
quatre fous 3 qui a été de qui et b3
amateurs c'est pas de là le pastaga nan
sérieux 2019 le beaucoup trop sérieux
triste à dire pas de g4 dans les parties
cop pastaga rien rien mais cette année
c'est un tat temps déjà par les deux
trois fois mettant un tel emploi du
temps que c'est faux que c'est pour ça
que ça m'étonne pas que tu joues pas le
suisse en réalité oui ses bras et c'est
pas sûr en dit juste que oui fenoyl ça
dépend on va dire que ça peut dépendre
de deux des grands prix non j'imagine
serre si ça se passe pas trop mal dans
les grands prix et qui se passe bien
dans les grands prix ce sera justement
ça arrive jury ne pas jouer si je me
qualifie par exemple alors après je sais
pas quelle est la date limite etc
mais si je peux donner ma réponse au
dernier moment et que je me qualifie via
la coupe du monde
là il ya des
enfin là je serais intéressé pour le
jouer juste parce que c'est intéressant
comme type de toit et du coup tu que
joue décontracté les derniers grands
prix du lait joue décontracté
c'est arrivé j'ai vu tout décontracté
après un dea de toute façon tu te garde
toutes les prépas j'imagine pour les
pour les candidats après ouais bon ça no
comments way que de sa pensée rien on va
souvent quand tu as une prog pas tu la
joues en feu
et puis en plus on jouerait à peu près
pas mais c'est clair que la préparation
pour les candidats ça peut aussi
impliquer des changements d'ouverture
penser rien bah comme a fait quand on
parlait great flu tout à l'heure il a
pas mal changé et sont faciles à changer
quelques petites rues dans son
répertoire avec les avec les grands prix
vous faites tout ça le clip est le clip
est prêt j'ai peur de voir la vidéo
tu peux regarder un tu veux tu peux tu
vas dire c'est horrible c'est fini vont
diront de faire un même et écrivit
soudan le chat c'est fini ouais c'est
fini
c'est fait plus bien l'impression que ça
me faisait un l'iphone ça sent ça va
être partagée avec le compte de chasse
comme tu vois c'est terrible non alors
que ces trois îles vanille ville veut
mettre le terrain 4 il veut insister sur
le pion c5 quand même mais là il est
bien avec les noirs mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas très bien
goupillé à sion qui a quatre équipes
françaises baril non mais t'as peur de
ligne 1 ben j'ai peur parce qu'il est
mais bon déjà tatoué fiq alain koffi cac
et prend 5 à temps ouais il faut prendre
ces quatre vous prend ses cinq de tête
et en dame prend à et tu te retrouves
avec deux pièces s'attaque à la fin non
est en baisse est aussi là dans cette
position qui est peut-être le meilleur
coût pour juste jouer tromper 3 en fait
ouais
sinon ouais ouais faut prendre ces
quêtes donc là un milou prend 6,5 sur un
an vous non mais une attaque et en ce
sens je vais dame 17 peut-être oui non
mais où il fallait jockey en c5 en fait
puisque j'ai eu en ce sens qu'il prend
kipruto pointe froid c'est pour ça que
j'ai joué qu'il faut prendre bessette
les normes bien oui on nous dit on dire
une bonne nimbo avec les couleurs
inversées
voilà j'ai pas assis ouais je vais vite
fait truc mais on déjà je vois le plein
de plus il est gratuit
c'est c'est dommage pour prague qu'il
est qu'il ait donné une partie cadeau
parce que là il peut il peut encore de
nouveaux ralliés en ligne et capo chichi
à tour comme des troncs mesdames v5
c'est bien joué il ya du foie schiste
qui rôdent non ouais un fou désiste
aussi du cac40 pour faire du kava lieu
de voilà sa route de partout là
et y'a le temps aussi qui rôde un génie
des douelles à même d'aller quelque part
les deux joueurs ont les 4 barres
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il a plus de
problème internet mais je pense qu'il a
un ping un peu dégueulasse d'ailleurs je
vais aborder les pings des deux joueurs
en cette iapp à cagnes et non pas si les
goûts au niveau du pin y soit 110 130
quoi ouais ça ouais c'est pas c'est pas
ouf mais bon ça passe ou ça passe
évidemment way
quant à la fibre main tu fais plus en
plus tôt à 10 15 hommes et même pas là
tu vois je suis à 80 at à 80 c'est un
peu dégueu pour la fibre bon alors
comment il la gagne ben il veut le
gagner
est ce que tu fais ah bah oui je fais
trois fois je suis peut-être non f3 je
pense que series injuste c'est juste 22
pas jouer ça c'est des coups tu vois tu
dois pas réfléchir tu dois juste le jour
tu as fait tes cartes et 4 mais c'est
terrible des images on ne veut pas voir
et va prendre deux cas très mais
vraiment à 2,5 a écrit blanc là c'est
peut-être pas fini c'est pas d'annecy
puisque et les pièces d'ange sont pas
bien placés et s'est jamais cavalier
blanc est vraiment à la rue mais ok il
se bat là quand même
ouais bah ouais s'il ya une passe et le
mériter j'ai accueilli 17 qui va arriver
cavaliers hafsi s'aliène tf6 les fronts
des cinq mérités ses mérites
on y va carrément la perdre ne pas jouer
trop ce n'est pas possible c'est
passionnant parce que là il reste plus
beaucoup de temps mais veillent à la
connexion qui peut le sauver
qui va arriver
koné
des connaître autour d un tombé huit
noms fou qui s'est encore cas et c'est
un an ça tient encore car ils disent
inquiets de jeu trompait 6 alors qu'ils
étaient trois à la fouille acquis de
fous des deux quelle idée getty quelle
folie cette partie à la délivrer
on a envie d'oublier c'est ça s est fou
mais c'est patine bien il va pas y avoir
un vainqueur dans cette partie à maxime
bon je pense soit les banques vont bien
et prend 1,7 mais bon c'est pas possible
elle était super énervés mais après à sa
décharge s'il a un mauvais internet il
doit être peut-être en fout près move
est hyper stressée de la connexion ouais
et puis bon c'est toujours plus facile
en commentant la cavalia 2 quai des
images insoutenables je vois que ludwig
de l'argent à pratiquer le cornetto
brest en fait que j'ai commencé à me
dire ça on pratique un peu le corner
taux de temps en temps on avait fait un
truc à cornetto pour pour ton tournoi
jamais j'avais fait un deal avec lui
qu'à chaque fois que tu as il s'en tire
avec la lune
j'espérais gagner ou que tu perdais
-s'il sentir annonce pour les finales
trouve quatre fous pranger 5e aux
petites pattes quand même
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
bon ça fait nul à l'arraché
ouais mais finalement méritée invite les
deux joueurs ont raté quand même pas mal
d'occasions ouais alors est ce qu'il va
nous refaire
bon normalement il va par ferrer 4 dame
prend la bonne marche trois rois enfin
ou alors mais je prépare le schweppes au
cas où m il y avait une partie s'était
pas une partie de toi contre mam et avec
cette variante la cia s'était terré
n'importe quoi s'étant rapidement
ouais c'est une copine cup manque je
savais que ce que je faisais n'était pas
bon mais je n'ai fait quand même à
l'étiage quatre là maintenant tu peux le
faire le truc avec f4 parce qu'il ya la
tournée par e1
c'est ça puis en plus la tour en f1 est
bien placé pour cent oui parce que ça va
taper sur f7 et y réfléchissez pas sas à
la salle à leur attaque améliorant aussi
pour ça il fait réfléchie j'ai envie de
dire chat échaudé craint l'eau froide
bon il y va des problèmes de sa pipe aux
indiens non les chats indien c'est
différent venons on nous dit que le
match et plus et plus et plus équilibré
que prévu oui alors après comme on
disait avec maxime le la connexion joue
aussi forcément un rôle parce que c'est
vrai que si tu as une ou deux parties
coup il ya perdu qui gagne ça fait pas 7
7 5
ça fait 9 3 c'est faire une différence
voilà comme dirait fabien 15 40 et 30 30
ah c'est pas la même quoi ouais ouais
la petite volée raison rien et ça change
beaucoup de chose à part donc la ilaha
illa le bon truc entre guillemets le
truc qui voulait avoir
[Musique]
et on va voir ce que ça donne
est ce que tu peux prendre réussissez
faire dam des trois pour f5 pas vous
prendre dans le prend et sur roc d'un
point f7 way et puis je pense aussi à du
f 6 1 t de pommes bien avec les noirs
injuste et tu vois le tas des pions
c'est peu gratuit voilà cinq c'est sa
prise prisé prise d'armes français même
quand prend il pas mal mais bon un tabou
tu laisses dessins que c'est ça que je
veux pas laisser messi non monsieur
sinon après ce grand état du but 4 mais
la dame prend est juste très fort
qu'ailleurs et que là j'ai déjà envie
d'examiner le prix de beauté
connais tu veux faire un premier set up
b3 rue89 s'il faut je suis un pro b sat
voir tu commences par un grand b 7 après
des 4 8 pouces et va faire qui fait déjà
très bonne ce que si tous la colonne tu
poses pas leader est lente et bien là
j'en prends et f6 là il est bien ouais
voilà c'était grand roque a tout le
temps fou prend f7 jour même des saintes
parce que là tu vas jouer aussi contre
le foie fuite et la belgique a très très
mal placée
d'ailleurs là j'ai juste une question
siégé trois ans faite à l'e3 avec kevin
à ton tour moi j'en ai fait pions
franges et 3 voilà 20.4 tourer c'est pas
assez bien tu fais comme je la tue dose
bien la difficulté tu prends des risques
mais maintenant au l'adamant j'ai dit
attention les yeux assez pole a comme
position la table je fais ici ja
demandent maintenant si je sais que j'ai
fait des trucs qui avec une tour achète
mais non c'est fini cette époque des
comptes mort pour cavaliers à chine pour
continuer le cimetière sur g 3 h troc et
tu bloques tout il n'a pas fait il
aurait peut-être dû dimitrov tu attends
j'ai pas regardé le tennis terrine
démographie devrait se faire éliminer
contre wawrinka mon avis bon ben ça jour
de l'an ce moment ça jean louis mais je
vais ça c'est un prono quoi ouais il a
perdu le premier set c'est chaud
krajinovic qui va souffrir
ay ay ay monte et qui n'a pas tenu le
cinquième belle histoire pour nico qui
se termine contrat qui se termine tout
juste son match
easy by ap une grosse surprise tête fit
all in
puis pour avoir voulu faire la bosse
fureur sur ce pauvre gueule le pauvre
via l mais qu'est ce qui nous a fait le
même temps 1 mais oui mais il a laissé
faire h 5 h 4 c'est pour ça que y'a
jamais je la laissais faire mais il a
maintenant des mares sont bien en fait
c'est terrible la différence une partie
maîtrisée et puis après son bien
c'est pas du tout finie cette partie on
est d'accord mais par rapport à tout à
l'heure c'est mon bébé
il est encore très bien il ya le plus de
recettes
la tour la torah 8 qui joue pas c'est la
4 a quand même mais bon c'est moins pire
quoi ah non mais moi je pensais qu'il
était bien avec les morts je me laisse
bercer par tes paroles mais non tu dis
n'importe quoi en fait baver j'ai tout
le temps n'importe quoi c'est très
dangereux femme a l'habitude maintenant
puisqu'on va grosses surprises n'ont
même pas vraiment un sur terre elle est
vraiment quelconque terre c'est une
surprise
il a gagné père il a gagné mais c'est
déjà très bien sur terre battue ils
marchent aussi à l'envi carré new state
un grosse méforme ces derniers temps
pour moi c'est pas une surprise donc là
ça va faire victoire pour monsieur wiley
mais il a gagné sur abandon
oui oui mais je sais je sais bien mais
ça me surprend pas qu'il ait gagné
après oui si l'autre avait pas été
blessé peut-être qu'il aura tout à
gagner j'en sais rien avait il est
blessé depuis un mouvement karen o bus
tas de façons web and haas a cédé way et
tout le circuit terre battue il n'a pas
du tout jeu comme il aurait dû
non c'est vers espère contre lajovic pas
du tout impossible très chiant lajovic
belle finale à monte-carlo non patchées
un jeu ouais ouais 4,10 à les jeux
jouera un billet pour pouvoir d'insultés
mekatrix du caddie c'est beaucoup quand
même
alors attention je viens d'être comparé
à lui un match à mouvaux je vis trop mal
je vis très mal
bon et sinon il a fini par gagner mais
c'est incroyable de bain ont fait
cavaliers h5 ton coup énorme après celle
en convient d'en gagner un
et ouais c'est tellement naturel dans
mon sens tu bouges plus un jeu bouge
plus une oreille quoi mais c'est
peut-être un tournant du match là qu'on
vient de vivre un il est aussi revenu à
un point ouais c'est ça peut être un
tournant parce que eh ouais il est ce
donc là il commence à se faire un petit
un petit dernier sur cette ligne l'un
doit commencer pas loin où il reste
encore un pas loin de 20 minutes de jeu
ouais à peu près il reste 17 minutes
donc il reste peut-être quatre parties
non je redis de 3 max non en fait ça
dépend ce que tu as un truc vicieux ci
reste trois ou quatre secondes sa
relance à lens comme une partie oui donc
suivant mais oui tu as raison parce
qu'une partie ça va faire huit minutes
ouais ça doit rester 3 way ont deux dans
certains cas mais plutôt 3 alors f6 tu
joues comment avec les blancs ici tu
fais des trois fous trois derniers
jouent tous cette ligne en ce moment
voici que tu peux pas avoir avec les
noirs n'ont de toute façon puisque dans
les nageurs tu fais des six ouais mais
ouais après c'est des trucs à kiev 5
j'ai vu c'est des trucs bien actif pour
les noirs donc ça donne pas très envie à
jouer avec les blancs après il ya des
idées des deux côtés mais mais je suis
pas fan des positions avec les mains de
manière générale je ne dépends prey sar
des plus simples avec les noirs n'ont
tué une tournée en blitz
mon parti non et si tu l'a travaillée
machin blitz
avec ce nouveau concept avec f5 j'aime
pas du tout qui a trouvé ce concept
d'ailleurs tu sais où tu gagnes ou tu
joues roses rouges
c'est vrai que là tu veux faire f4 non
si jamais chez nous mais ce que tu
penses que wailly prend le match un peu
par dessus la jambe et c'est pour ça que
qu'il a des positions parce que j'ai
plus un son qui sort pas très bien des
ouvertures en général ouais bon après
c'est naturel aussi un tabac pas
toujours très motivés dans ce genre de
match ça je je comprends je vais me les
toutes les peines à me débarrasser de
biens gauchy et avait fait une grotte à
un moment donné pour un oui pour montrer
qui était le patron
pour montrer que c'était l'état d'esprit
est beaucoup plus important que la
matière et tu l'avais gagné d'ailleurs
la grappe non bien sûr
je crois bien frazer qu'on se refasse un
match contre rennes chez carbo c'est fou
là je commence à fatiguer ça y est tu un
ps tu sens la difficulté du commentaire
j'aurais dû prendre la pose qui m'était
offerte il ya quarante cinq minutes ça
chez elle ça c'est comme au tour de
france battus fait d'illusions dans les
deux premiers cols et là tu commence à
sentir fou ouais tu ou alors tu vois tu
veux faire un peu chaud sur le tu fais
ta tête tu vas prendre les points du
maillot à pois
ouais hein
ti pierre rolland fait d'attac et puis
après les quatre d'or se réveille et hop
je crois par bon d'ailleurs pierre
rolland je suis dur il en forme il fait
des trucs pas mal c'était qui les
échappées catastrophique des
spécialistes diabète il y avait même ça
remonte trop dures en ans jacky durand
mais bon il était pas sic attaque ça non
je pensais vraiment des trucs plus
récente du ca tous ceux qui avaient
[Musique]
conquis se spécialiser dans la barre ou
d'offres c'est un état d'esprit c'est
sympa aussi de faire les trucs en tête
baissée rectorat qui finissent jamais
les coûts quoi tu les vois tout le temps
à l'avant il gagne jamais une course il
se fond tout le temps grâce c'est vrai
c'est spécial tu te demandent enfin il
décore le peloton va tu demandes à quoi
ils servent à thomas voeckler nom thomas
voeckler à une employée
non parce que je viens il avait une
intelligence de course après j'étais
enfin de la personne d'ailleurs ça j'ai
un peu spéciale est par contre 113 mon
consultant d'air oui mais après il met
une année il avait eu le maillot jaune
pendant un moment il résiste à foin
ouais en 2011 ouais ouais il résistait
bien ça je me rappelle d'ailleurs celle
qu'avait réussi à taiping cette année là
je sais comment vous avez fait est là
pour l'année pour l'année prochaine tu
vois qui le retour de froome au l'agencé
je me suis intéressé aussi fils cette
saison c'est terrible du coup la gérer
et je commence à regarder le giro j'ai
même pas regarder ce que ça va donner
aujourd'hui tarbais mais à mon avis
where au beach a réussi à perdre le truc
l'art oblige à l'an dernier pour le
podium il avait craqué et là ça va être
carapace 1 s'il n'y a pas une connerie
bon après j'ai pas regardé s'il ya un un
contre la montre
j'ai l'impression que l'adf juste pour
parler de la partie il me semble que les
blancs sont complètement foutu
voilà bah c'est mérité oui oui non mais
ça oui je disais rien puisque tu le
savais pas va y avoir du tour des huit
vous prend h3 ouais pas de changement au
général
du coup carapace à 2002 avance sur
nibali et sur un trani pas d'idée pompe
a il est bon le requin il y avait un
fort vent fait qu'il ya un vélo qui
avait créé la prophétie de sa victoire
au tour de france depuis si les crampes
dans les jambes
enfin forum forum spécialisé les alizés
j'ai pu vélo est un truc je crois qu'il
sait faire un hacker ce que sur tu
empruntes froid d'un projet 6 il ya le
fou ici ce qui traîne à la fin ouais il
faut 5 et 10 h 4 parfums cermak et tous
avant oui c'est un hacker tout seul
tati fatigue un peu dans il fait comme
toi ouais mais les deux sont fatigués je
pense qu'il ya leurs deux des partis qui
vous c'est dommage alors qu'on te voit
pas plus sur les arénas kings pardon
après vu ton calendrier c'est normal
aussi mais ouais bah si je veux en faire
mon retour de moreuil ça va être cool
ouais voilà prêt j'ai jamais fait après
c'est spécial parce que du coup comme
enfin là ça va aller parce que tu as un
hello faible entre guillemets mais 2900
ça va aller mais genre c'est pas si
simple à gagner si tu as trois mille
3000 sens que tu joues que contre les
meilleurs à chaque fois oui le sel et du
coup pour entamer les séries c'est dur
en fait ce n'est pas si évident parce
que si tu te fais à parier contre
meilleur à moernach au épique temps
chaînes comme ça tu vas avoir du mal à
même en scène tu vas avoir du mal à
garder le strict et des mecs à 2004 2005
ils vont jouer des et sans compter que
de toute façon tu mettras toujours plus
de temps à battre hammer qu'un 2005
avait train 2003 mais du coup ça rentre
tournoi marrant oui
howe à 100 je suis très longue de fin
j'ai pas pêche
j'ai pas utiliser le système mais bon je
veux pas jouer marina yung avec
l'intention de gagner à tout prix non
mais je sais bien mais c'est juste pour
dire que le que du coup le format rend
le truc intéressant parce que ça ouais
ça tu étais quand même favori par
rapport aux joueurs moins forts parce
que fatalement ouais mais toi tu joueras
jamais un mec plus fort que toi alors
que moi par exemple je tombais contre
toi tu as quand même un avantage quand
tu es plus fort au final mais il suffit
que tu vois dans les deux parties où on
ne joue qu on fasse à 1 et du coup là
c'est fait à temps perdu dans fait oui
ok on peut tout peut arriver sur une
partie bien sûr surtout que en plus la
difficulté c'est que comme le niveau des
adversaires changent et que les parties
s'enchaînent tu peux avoir des passages
à vide des liens on tente passage amis à
oui mais c'est vrai qu'il a perdu les
dernières je suis comme ça je pensais
qu'ils étaient revenus à plus à mende
oui là il ya le dessin de qui arrive
donc je pense être salée pouvait faire
un mais bon au mieux ça fait trois ans
après tout est jouable ou l'état tant il
reste on va je vais essayer de vous
regarde faire profiter la pose aussi
pour être des saints ils nous disent là
ils mettent un message officiel que oui
oui oui il y mène quatre et demi à 1
2000 à sur les cinq dernières parties
donc il a quand même passé prenant on
peut pas dire qu'il a passé un coup
d'accélérateur dans le sens où il était
quand même assez raide c'est plutôt
morgan en date un peu craqué ouais ouais
le x 3 x 3 prépare b5
sinon oui kg propre petit rock et puis
b5 et grands axes étaient très loin
c'est dans l'esprit après ouais il
prépare son petit g5 mais tu dois je
crois que ça va arriver un peu trop tard
l'attak blanche l'art d'être quand même
plus rapide c'est vrai qu'il a un coût
d'ouvrir
trois cavaliers 7
donc ils anticipent un peu bessin
quelque part ouais mais bon c'est
terrible parce que je voi x 3 tirs au
québec a aussi toujours moins il ya
aussi des zytek n 5
on peut tout de suite qu'elle prend 1,5
des 4 5 et quelque chose comme ça ah non
c'est terrible c'est terrible et les
noirs sont vraiment pas bien mon rock on
allait manger sain gym age in ou qui
j'ai six régies pour pas non c'est 5
bonjour quatre ferme andré il faut aussi
regarder si je peux prendre en d5 et
prendre cinq points mais ça je la mets
vraiment le trou 8 c'est bizarre je crie
pas une once de contre jeu qui va b 5
baies 5 paraît logique où la déconnexion
pourquoi regarde en bas c'est le cadeau
des connexions fernanda sac à dos a fait
ils jouent des quatre langues et il veut
jouer sur la fourchette assure pions
prend pour jouer 5
oui si j'en avais parlé une délicate qui
j'ai six autres qui prend 4 puis on
prend 1,5 et qui avait projeté trois
peut-être une idée sérieuse
là je pense qu'ils feront quand je
reprends et qui prend 5 se donne pas
martèle fois celle qui est toujours qui
est en dehors du jeu terrifiant ces
trois des quatre fois haye qui a été
complètement à enterrer il pensait au 6
mai puis en tranches france tu prends
dans lequel tu prends et cinq ans du
coup j'aurais plutôt garder le fou mais
est ce qu'on peut pour lui ce qu'on peut
faire plus on prend des cats avec les
noirs maintien c'était ma question
ouais aussi c'est pour ça aussi que je
pensais que 34 est ce que tu veux quand
même prendre ces 3 et 7 donne des choses
pratiques mais je pense que je ne
pourrais m'en fous des trois français
trois chats voilà parfois je pouvoir
avoir quelques actions des quatre daims
prouvé qu'elle n'achète pas votre foi
trautmann dame f4 peut-être 1,6 avec
racisme et la joojoo tour bien qu'une
voiture a sauvé quatre lycées 600 corps
pense qu'en théorie c'est mieux pour le
blanc après bon même quelqu'un c'est pas
gratuite non je g62 question s'il ya
coupé simple trait toujours la
découverte tous les saints que ça peut
être ça peut être un coup mais là il a
il ajoute quand même eu beaucoup de
cavaliers pour pas grand chose là bas
pour laisser l'autre joué ses pions au
la 3d en tête des trois tout de suite si
monde vous prendrez des trois-epis crème
des cinq échecs comme ça tu échanges des
dames
voilà vous avez 5 et rigaux là les pions
or ça va faire + 5 promis un appui 5 ça
commence à la question c'est ce qu'il
nous reste une partie je pense que oui
on restait trois temps des connexions
pour ruiz non il est reconnecter donc à
temps non il est déconnecté ça est
déconnecté ça a peut-être faire que +3
aïe aïe aïe aïe j'ai mal pour oui
celle-là maxime elle fait mal on sait
très bien qu'à deux secondes
il va pas récupérer la connexion à ça
fait mal maxime c'est rim
ouais ah c'est peut-être un tournant du
match peut-être un nouveau tournant
surtout comment ça marche la reine c est
ce qu ils attendent
normalement non toi que tu as une minute
ou quoi mais pas plus sain on nous écrit
que la chine va avoir du mal à vendre la
5g
mais c'est un tournant du match là ça
ils pouvaient tuer le match
ouais je pense connaître grand chose
alors à temps en plus c'est d'une folle
aurait donc si c'est connoté que je le
feu au cul si je pense qu'on le follow
toujours
moi je vais faut de l'autre aussi au cas
où si on proteste je me rappelle que ça
faisait des trucs bizarres que vers
follereau avant après celle parties
jouées ouais ce que toi un grand
classique pointu non seulement tu joues
mais en plus tu suis tu suis tes
équipiers tu regardes la partie en même
temps ouais ouais c'est pour ça aussi
que l ai du mal à prendre le pas ainsi
je prends très au sérieux mais qu'un
fils de c'est beaucoup trop
ouais c'est trop long mais tu as fait un
feed back dans ce sens là ou pas parce
que moi j'ai fait un feed back dans ce
sens là je me suis fait je me suis fait
défoncer ouais ouais bah oui on aime on
dit que ben après pour certains c'est
bien que cette cadence je leur ai dit
pareil je leur ai dit fais 5 plus de ce
serbe elle ampute non mais par exemple
le formaldéhyde battle royale est pas
mal c'est dix plus de l'ouest est 10
plus zélés battle royale
c'est déjà mieux non mais au moins 10 +
2 15 +15 cela c'est quoi ces 15 + 10
n'ont même alors j'ai bien plus de ses
15 plus de rmc un peu long et qu'un truc
du genre à refuser 15 plus de simples
allons bientôt plus de j'aime pas
puisque ça fait mine de rien qui passent
la soirée quoi ces trois heures ouais
non mais disent + 2 les matches il durer
quand même une demi heure de moins ce
serait bien quoi
et n'oubliez pas d'heure de follow la
chaîne ça que j'ai pas dit mais faut le
la chaîne chaise com fr on va remettre
un lien vers ta chaine maxime
il faut que les gens suivent la chaîne
c'est très important et donc ton
prochain ce crime c'est en français
c'est de combien c'est le 21 je crois
voilà je vais adorer demain mais du coup
ces patients la chaîne c'est sur la
chaîne de chasse comme way est mon
prochain je pense que j'ai 18 c'est pas
marina bay street des bruits de la
norvège justement comme il est le
nouveau format atx et ce point commun
multiple temps je pense que je peux te
dire quand le cal date il est inscrit en
français je crois que je peux trouver ça
moi je peux tu ressens unis
c'est le 21 mai j'en ai deux mois 21
juin c'est en français un étang à un
autre en anglais mais celui en français
c'est le 21 juin c'est ça 12 pieds
[Musique]
9h à 21h c'est ça ouais bah non ce sera
pendant le 21h 23h
ok donc le 21 tu fais l'aréna kings
voilà bah c'est cool peut-être on se
rencontrera coiffant ps et pas sur un
temps la tension faire très attention
parce que hikaru quand même génie en pls
une fois ci je sais après j'ai dû subir
ces menaces de mort bon il a pas donné
suite pour le moment mais bon ça répare
ils m'ont donc et non mais il a toujours
pas de connexion d'ailleurs ouais
peut-être que wayne nancy c'est reparti
on n'a pas les rouges
non mais c'est c'est quand même un peu
pénible que le match face on va pas dire
qu'ils jouent là-dessus mais tu vois si
je trouve que ça casse un peu le way
complètement ça casse un peu le rythme
quoi tu as quand même envie de suivre un
truc qui se joue qui se joue aux échecs
et joue pas la connexion
cette attaque qui a aidé quatre temps
pense quoi d'ailleurs dans l'est mais
ces matches qui jouait le truc avec x 4
si mathieu le jour où tu peux faire
confiance un nom mais je sais plus si le
dessus par je sais qu'ils jouent sur
kadhafi ce site est payée 4 5 et 6 des 7
juillet 4 x 4 bon j'ai vu dans le jeu ça
parle de manu ferrand je vois que c'est
du très haut niveau quand même mais tu
sais qu'il a un sweat-shirt et je sais
c'est pour ça que ça parle mais c'est
lui qui m'a appris l'existence de
l'extraordinaire sont riches
j'ai vu jésus dit c'est extraordinaire a
laissé un concert avec quelque part
c'est pourquoi les ic insights et tu
traînes pas trop sur twitter en dehors
de ça assez peu quoi au final puisque
bon problème c'est que wade a trop le
temps après ça peut te remplacer netflix
parfois les bons ou et parfois non mais
si je vois des trucs sympas et cetera
j'y vais je suis potez quand même
incroyable
je devrai c'est triste c'est triste
c'est triste il faut ensuite où sont
ensuite tous vos thèses là bas chaque
fois j'en vois des raids à vos thèses
tout temps à la fin tout le temps
j'exagère mais de temps en temps si si
si si aucun jeu j'en vois j'envoie des
règles à des raids à krikor aussi
j'avais joué avec mon propre châssis que
c'était extraordinaire et les cabinets
j'ai jamais vu stream et imaginer
lustrinelli coécrit crûment brésilien
dans le coup tf1 portugais mais faut que
tu fu l'oim balma follow ya pas
longtemps ya genre deux semaines à ma
photo c'est faux l'eau de qualité
ça important c'était comme sur facebook
quand tu recevais les like les line de
qualité à l'elite qui servent à rien
c'est la plupart servent à rien tu as
beaucoup de laïcs lambda way i am et
donc tuer sinon sur le sur les sur les
plateformes stream genre stones ou quoi
tu regardes je suis pas du genre stone
ce qu'il ya quelques jours j'ai bien
joué
damien non je regarde un moment je
regardais un tout petit peu là comme ça
pour voir mais ouais c'est un rêve
qu'est ce que j'ai et tu connais zerator
ou genre de choses ou azéma tort non
dragon dans une lettre dans un future
halle ont atteint qu'on fasse un petit
un petit stage switch ya peut-être un
truc marrant surtout prend 1,4
maintenant il faut prendre d'essai je
pensais fou g5 apsys et d'un promu si ce
n'est qu'on 17 et plus simple ouais bah
je divague aussi un ouais c'est normal
oui c'est le dernier avant la pause a
priori meilleurs ni non il est juste un
problème dans la position d'apple
probablement dans prague
enfin il importe de mou portant rien
n'est pas mais payet pas très bien avec
les noirs dans mois après tu prends tu
joues qui sydom c6 de paris va où ça tu
vas tu arrives à survie en instant mais
bon c'est or c'est pas l'américain ses
pattes et même des huit prises va
prendre ces six dans le chat s'appelle
de marcus
c'est un joueur de league of legends qui
joue un peu aux échecs et je crois qu'il
avait joué une partie
entre toi je crois que j'ai bien passé
elles n'ont cours tu vois oui je vais a
écrit quand il était d'usagé eut lu des
trucs passé comme ça qui te connaissais
ouais mais c'est pas son nom bien
évidemment et c'est son pseudo
simplement plus marcus gens ne devraient
pas un ex en dhr mais je crois que ça ne
me dit rien
après c'est à dire quand tu étais petit
voilà les petites parties de même deux
jeunes sont durs à se rappeler est en
fait du coup on se rappelle qu'on songe
aux échecs contre maxime vachier lagrave
mais l'inversé n'est pas forcément vrai
quoi au jeu de à mal deux parties mais
bien évidemment non autour de 13 ans
ermite un traitement sera plaisir mais
bon après c'est peut-être pas le bon nom
qui connaît un maquillage tout le monde
là est ce qu'on va faire tout reprendre
et 6,6 et meilleure classe affaires 2
pions plus ça fait quel point la pause
ça va faire cinq pions de sa f3 pion par
dont quatre pions même genre et je tombe
un jour à jouy le mat on va du coup ça
s'ils tournent à +4 et normalement ça
devrait être au bord en petite pause de
cinq minutes
ouais allez allez c'est parti petite
pause a de suite maxime ya cette hausse
[Musique]
et on est de retour maxime pour les
bullet cette partie ça va bientôt
commencer je france
ouais il ya des joueurs qui viennent
d'apparaître à l'écran
bon signe ça et donc ça veut dire que ça
va démarrer maxime et ça va être le
bullet de tous les dangers pour oui oui
bon iman de coeur mais ça peut ça
pourrait être serré mais les liens de
connexion quoi voilà s'il est déconnecté
ça peut ça peut aller vite
intéressant ça est intéressant ça tu
vois finalement ce truc de connexion
c'est que ça laisse un petit suspense au
match où elle passe
ouais c'est pas comme ça on a envie mais
vous essayez de voir le point positif
quoi ouais parce que c'est vrai que
sinon on avis aurait pas plus quatre
mais peut-être plus tôt +7 +81 ouais
ouais
et après il se passe bien il a un fils a
raté des trucs aussi la peine donc une
très bonne connexion il faut bien c'est
bien le dire il est un peu jamila
revenant de ces services est sûr que bon
quand je critique certains leurs poumons
si c'est normal qu'il soit encore 1
mondial un rival n'a que 14 ans encore
une fois ainsi la l'écran c'est toujours
plus facile j'ai remarqué tu vois
souvent quand je vois les parties en
doublettes tu vois je suis pas du tout
impressionné dans ne parle à coeur en
fait ouais alors quand en face
ouais ouais non mais c'est sûr ces
mégères semblent comptés d'extérieur
enfin quand tu es dedans en fait à ça
t'a pas de recul oui bien sûr ce que tu
dois calcul est beaucoup plus de choses
quand tu joues et donc ouais tu choisis
pas ton truc tu choisis pas ton nom -
non non tu es des denrées allez c'est
parti donc prague amanda a alors là
c'est étonnant cette première ouverture
de oui je sais pas si ça existe maxime
et c'est la première fois que je vois ça
c'est très clairement un bug
enfin un missclick c'est clairement un
bug en train de se marrer à la caméra en
fait oui ça le fait marrer quand il
quand il se trompe donc capcom alors fou
des trois fous des princes c'est assez
étonnant ce qui fait avec les blancs
mais non mais c'est pas si mal
maintenant tu peux pas vraiment prendre
le quatrième petit rock décès de cinq
buts cavaliers 17 et rock
kessé rock quand même et il prend 1,5
mais il va pas y avoir un problème de
encore un meyrin ge peu tu perds tu peux
faire tourner vers la mer était aurait
pu commencer par que moi c'était très
fort sur clio iv là tu joues avec et 34
sur quelqu'un 3g prend note
pointe-claire bonté mieux apte à fin
décembre un dessin qui s'est pas mal
mais bon c'est pas fini je pensais pour
savoir sur qui il prend 1,5 fallait
jouer et c'était un objet qui a tancé
c'est vraiment fini sur ses sens non
c'est pas fini je ne la finissent pas
fini un d'accord et pour s'affaler jouer
je pense que certaines personnes
falaises autour un salaire plus fort bon
allez va quand même revenir en d3 et là
y'a pas f3 ouais mais bon c'est quand
même une pièce un ouais c'est une pièce
c'est gratuit pour le faut je ne le
prendrai qu'un seul ami il faisait 5
bah oui mais un problème c'est gagné
pour l'événement bref ces dames profs ou
3m et un plus beau mais qu'est-ce qui
souvent foot et wet
j'ai trop l'habitude de mes matches avec
cas où on a 45 secondes
un coup d'arrêt après après il faut pas
oublier qu'ils ont peut-être des
difficultés de connexion je serai ouais
mais tu à sa cause le truc ça font
encore mais si ils ont des connections
pas si mal mandature 34 on a été surpris
on prend un rouge et trois allers il
faut il faut lutter pour oui il faut
essayer de résister contre bas pièces de
moins nettes 3,8 surprend 17 et ya maths
et s'affaissa relire revient à 3 points
d'écart bah écoute c'est plutôt de
mauvaise augure pour le joueur chinois
cette première partie ouais après la
première pas toujours mais ouais mais
bon en attendant en attendant il revient
à 3 points il réussit pas à s'échapper
non bien sûr il réussit pas à s'échapper
a réussi pas faire l'écart pour le
moment c'est pas complètement rassurant
bien ouais ouais
heureusement qu'il n'a pas si rogers en
face la valise
oui on est y aurait été facile alors est
ce que là les blancs sont pas mieux
maxime parce que on réussit à faire x 4
pour ses sets bien je pense que c'est
beau me rend peut-être ai-je eu de
gagnant
ouais ça paraît difficile alors ça c'est
pas mal joué mais j'ai dit ça il ya des
cinq qui va tomber
et puis v7 après un mois gratuit tandis
que puisque près d'un de prendre 5 n'est
pas finie finit pas qu'un pion de moins
mais bon nul à tomber 8 tu vois tu as
des chances pratique
ouais à 5 dont qui protège son pion
plage orageux dams et 6 3 pour le jour
de pétrole
rien n'a changé si c'est peut-être
savoir h4 voilà roger deux importantes
je mangeais d'un moment c'est une fête
du mawlid kg 38 laurent gillet juste
croquer à protéger la vie
comment est-ce qu'on va pousser cette
majorité allèles dame maxi 4 bref deux
donc plutôt d'un de ses trains et met
des jeunes hommes descendre là et de
prendre ce que l'on fait pour empêcher
tombe bien sauf que via damas chama très
bon mais il n'a pas vu du coût l'aï
réussi à échanger des tours et encore
maintenant encore pour 5 heures gagnant
ainsi la rive levé je te retrouves
bayari facile tu veux leurs ancêtres ça
c'est fini
et s'il gagne cette partie il
reprendrait il reprendra jusqu'à la
finition
il a obtenu un pion pas ch / g caprice
prise
il va y avoir h 3 h de et agen dame
allait peut-être tour e tour f4 sur f3
jeu 3 mais surtour des 2 h 3 ça a pas
l'air de 7,6 simple maxime
quoique non monsieur lettre pour ces
villes tombées vie tu es le roi peut pas
passer de pionsat ouais ouais mais si tu
pourras changerait juste attendre alors
fait que tu peux pas attendre si tu dois
jour âge 5 et la tête ou rejet - mais
bon ça devient très très long à dire
subtil un as assez bien joué mais non là
tu joues rouges 5 le tour pour dire ça
il devrait pouvoir tenir avec les noirs
après c'est peut-être pas idiot pour le
oui de jouer un peu parce que c'est lui
qui mène au score il n'a pas bougé sein
de tours j'ai enfin ensuite été obligé
de revenir en suisse oui du coup c'est
plus 3 il reste 22 minutes
il ya encore le temps pour pour prague
ananda mais faut pas perdre de temps la
question pour les manches cette fumée
faut encore se rappeler en bullet c'est
pas facile en irak et à peut-être f4 qui
va arriver
joe fawcett français j'imagine vous
croyez que ça tissier qui est tranquille
[Musique]
6,25 food et deux de mes six poutres
autres du juin tu commenceras en danger
cette salle une tête de truc tu prends
g7 keyyo 6 le roman de retenir en 8
ensuite tu fais un petit saut
non il est revenu en f3 il a pas but
maxime n'ont ils pas forcément du bien
parce que ya pas de gains mais non à
google c'est juste
tu joues quoi bon alors du coup ça
ressemble un peu à une passe et pas que
c'est une pire quoi améliorer cet
incident survient souvent vers quoi
émettre un cas lancé 500 prend de
curieux quatre normalement pas il prend
le fou il va reprendre le pion ouais il
faut à six autres champs ouais il est
maître des cases noires des cases
blanches pardon à cause du passé car tu
joues pour dire que les jetteront tour
des huit c'est fort on ne peut pas
prendre ces six parce que le cavalier de
est sous pression mais il n'a pas vu
c'est marrant il rate des trucs assez
marrant ouais c'est là que tu vois
vraiment la différence avec avec le top
mondial quand on regarde vos matchs avec
ce soit n'a quoi que ce soit ce que ce
soit magnus ce soit gris tchouk ou quoi
c'est quand même une autre galaxie un v6
les ja oui oui non mais après s'il ya
des habitudes qui rend compte c'est à
dire quand vous l'êtes évidemment tu as
des joueurs qui sont plus spécialistes
que d'autres par exemple je de cas reste
en prise voilà prête quand j'ai joué mon
alors après il était payé par la
commission les aussi déjà en lice et le
rapport va jouer contre ma came as well
et vonn s'était pas avec avec tout le
monde sauf et elles feront bientôt sur
rhodia il va être très forts en bulles
atteint et le pingouin
non c'est ton en dessous je suis je
pense que je suis aussi oui femme elle
pas maintenant mais il y a
j'étais habitué aux boulettes j'étais
largement devant non bien sûr
le pingouin c'est surtout la vitesse 1
après leur déconvenue des cornichons
c'est plus fort que le pingouin
oui oui belle époque de toute façon
j'étais et je crois que je tourne à 50%
qui était jeune mais à l'époque six
essais ah ouais ça fait plus fort vous
allez je jouais tous les jours tu
devrais tu devais sacrément bien jouer
mes maquettes et quand même devant on
accueille des gens je mange à 30% à west
est ressorti à la casse a toujours été
le médecin
le meilleur a derrière ils magnus
maintenant mais ça fait très longtemps
que ses deux meilleurs joueurs de bullet
du monde ont valu bien sûr elle a
vraiment un truc hein pour ça ouais
alors cette position est ce que on vise
bien sûr la casse des 5 avec les blancs
moi je suis un geek sm5 donc là oui
juste pour faire un plan sur un point
sur le classement il reste 18 minutes il
a + 4 ça commence à prendre forme
ouais c'est fini ça une de pocket
tu as beau match ouais agréable à suivre
mais il ya eu quand même un peu de
suspense tour à trois tours ces trois
jolis noms ouais mon poste et en large
sur tous les 5 mais bon les personnes
l'a vu lors des 6 et 9 ans mattie et
j'ai pas trouvé le monde va gagner 4-1
pions gratuit mailly est tous rangs
ouais c'est joli ça parce que sur dame
prend tout reprend on peut pas protéger
le foie fuite et la tue un mois 3,8 +5
et je crois aussi qu'il veut pas
travailler tu voles d'anne frank si
c'est suivi de lutte
alors là kitsch pêche nikos qui va jouer
la vente avec les idées 5
oui je veux c'est vraiment venu à la
mode dans cette variante à la suite du
match
je crois que c'est le problème en mai au
blanc ouais c'est parce que c'est entre
les mains de magnus avec les noirs donc
là 16 minutes à jouer
kaïs et 3 nivard viser la case de quatre
fois et bien jouer il va envoyer c4 c5
si peu j'imagine que ça va pour le nord
alors gagner peut-être j'ai cinq ans
moins un jour une lettre c'est plus
agréable en tout cas ils soutiennent pas
puisque je prends ça mais j'aurai le
tour c'est 8,7 qu'elles valent ces 7 est
un problème chaude français
après j'aime pas mais ça va pour les là
il envoie un peu comme dans une est
indienne ouais donc prison f5 qui va
reprendre
voilà près de deux pour le troc à ses
fans sa peau et qui réfléchit à ce qu'on
peut jouer avec g3 ici
ensuite et c'est de sacrifier la tour en
h3 danse est un peu dur mais d'ailleurs
c'est fou parce que normalement oui les
connexions internet qui marche i joue
sanchez d'autres comme kiné 3000 en
bresse ouais ça doit être aujourd'hui
qu'il va avoir des problèmes
ouais ça a du mal ton aujourd'hui ce que
3000 en bullet c'est vrai que après ils
doivent ouvrir zoom et les caméras c'est
peut-être ça qui le met dans le dur
c'est jouissif mais je rappelle le match
contre bordeaux a rapporté qu'il avait
pas la connexion adéquat
jouer c'est un peu dur ambulatoire tu
peux g5l à tours angers 4e être bien
placé va faire 3 et vincent deux fois en
trois matches est assez fou quoi le
deuxième cure gratuit qui tombe c'est ça
la tombola et bakary 28 refus +28 saveur
il a refusé de prendre le purgatoire il
veut toujours f5
du coup les pions sont gratuits et il va
en reprendra en f3 non suivi et orange 2
on la jouera le food et 4g là maintenant
tour f k
dix essais 6 il envoie le pion est un
thème de la tour et en plus elle fois
celles qui couvrent voix
braga lambda qui revient quatre points
d'écart il reste de l'asie minutes
ouais donc gers il reste cinq parties
max à mon avis ouais moi ça dépend là
monsieur ça peut t'aider partie d'un
autre côté il peut te faire ce qu'on
appelle une grille tchouk oui tu es bien
placé pour le savoir mais je crois que
même sa charité cette technique glace
effet que c'est contre toi donc ça avait
été inaugurée ouais
oui bon après les gueux la sortie le jeu
main mais ça c'était moyen c'était assez
dégueu d'entasser des jeux je crois que
j'en étais tu y es très fier en plus ben
oui mais après c'est payet mais pas de
règlement donc
d'ailleurs je crois qu'elle toujours pas
vraiment doublement non après ils
peuvent pas y faire grand chose des
moyens d'en rajouter artificiellement du
temps pour faire en sorte que si le mec
continue tour contre tours oui tu peux
tu peux tu as tu peux le faire
voilà une pièce qui tombe voir tu peux
mettre des pénalités mais bon après ça
bien subjectif ouais les pénalités ça
vient subjectif non mais le truc peut
rajouter du temps c'est pas mal parce
qu'en fait tu peux avoir un arbitre peut
enfin il considère ce qu'il veut après
l'arbitré croyait tous les dents dans
tout art est simple ils n'ont aussi
après rajouter du temps le problème
c'est petit des jalons dans ma mémoire
ça empêcherait les mène de faire ça
parce que
passer du coup ils ne feraient pas et du
coup personne le ferez puisse arranger
le problème en fait voilà mai mais du
coup toi tu préfères pas le système de
sept mois je trouvais que c'était
beaucoup plus sympa ouais j'ai bien aimé
le système de soldes
menaka il a été content quoi quoi n'a
qu'a été contre le système de cette je
crois que ça favorise les joueurs plus
frais mais je suis pas d'accord écrit
trouve c'est beaucoup plus marrant pour
le public aussi regarder parce qu'au
moins un des boîtes à des parties
chaudes quoi voilà ça a l'air de bien
tenir pour pour oui mais bon prague
amanda qui résiste après tu as os et des
parties elles font ça fait ça fait
tourner pour tu vas le faire tous rêvent
de fouler 6 mai retraite et échanger des
pièces il rame un peu un pour la gagner
le match oui blain pour la peine y de
littérature en plus ça il gagne
peut-être un effet la technique ils
gagnent du temps peut-être à
volontairement mais en tout cas la
partie a duré beaucoup plus longtemps
qu'elle n'aurait ouais bon ça non mais
il ne le fait pas exprès déjà par là en
plus il va se le gagner mathématiquement
quoi ouais mais elle n'appelle pas la
lignée celle là ouais c'est maintenant
le rôle option avance
attendez non je fais arrange pas la tour
cette fois f3 3,7 au roi qui montent
comme ce bon bah il se bat bien ouais
bah ouais c'est même lui qui va jouer
pour la gagner enfin bon ouais c'est
gagnant il va peut-être même la gagner
eh ouais incroyable il reste dans le
match et coûte
il survit ouais la brique est mort de
rire
l'écurie en fait d'équipés rigole c'est
un concept
ouais bah écoute il reste il reste suit
minute et il reste donc trois parties et
ya trois points d'écart ça peut être la
remonte à da et non celle là mais j'y
crois pas mais bon on en a vu d'autres
ouais ouais oui c'est pas paris c'est
sûr que c'est sur que c'est pas le psg
mais bon on regarde le barça contre
liverpool est ce que tu t'es attendait
non mais c'est un pays mais c'est vrai
qu aux échecs il ya moins de ya moins de
surprise je trouve les joueurs tiennent
leur rang souvent dans les sports
individuels
j'ai l'impression c'est plus facile de
tenir son rang
il après le foot aussi c'est différent
mon tennis est facile facile de tenir
trois mâts près le niveau est tellement
homogène en fait on sent pas compte mais
est ce que tu dis que c'est sur des
matches vraiment 7
normalement ce sinon un joueur est
meilleur tu vas voir aux échecs le
meilleur joueur va tenir son rang mais
déjà tu tu as quand même le phénomène
des nuls et puis voilà sur une partie
c'est toujours difficile de faire la
différence mais là dedans les speech est
quand même ça c'est plein de partie
c'est c'est pour ça ouais ouais ça tient
bien le rang oui le pharmacien demande
donc cette finale et ce qui va et ce qui
va la tenir avec les noirs probable il
est quand même un peu moins bien moi le
beau temps de sa jeunesse et ses finales
va normalement six nuls en moi je
détiens en q1 mais flottement mais aucun
traitement
l'animé on a ça commence à être mieux
mais tu mèneras ans et trois clés en
métro ça commence à devenir vite devenir
désagréable ce cas il joue vite
il a le bon plan si revient à -2 à el
ouaer 3 comment cet horaire 3 que ça
c'est connu à une vieille partie de la
sqaf je crois comme ça oui c'est oui
fait la même chose que oui on a tu
prends tu joues kms est encore solide un
barème est bon
tu es solidité solide
il va falloir la tenir ouais mais avant
encore rendre des minutes sur le chrono
c'est vrai que ça mange le chrono c'est
vrai que ça mange le chrono alors
attendu comment est ce qui va passer la
balle passe je prends je crois que tu
joues à 6 ouais
ces forteresses un nom je peux pas
donner une fois aussi parce que ta
fougue 4 je prends reprend 2,4 après
lequel tu as besoin du faux 6 pour
fermer la laci c'était gris choo que on
serait partis prompt à balayer non fair
play fair play mais d'un autre côté il a
match gagné par ce geste il ne sait pas
ça généralement dans ces moments-là
tubercules fans attendus c'est vrai tu
as raison tu n'as pas le temps donc fair
play et donc il reste 4 minutes 30
et normalement je vois pas comment il y
aurait plus de marty juste pas possible
mais un match qui aurait été serré
finalement jusqu'au bout un way we match
était intéressant à suivre
on s'était évidemment très haut niveau
mais quand même ça se joue à minden dont
ils sont jeunes encore un oui oui bah
oui ils sont jeunes
le chinois après on verra un v6 yves
s'il veut se débarrasser de dirigeants
qui joue qui au prochain je vais jeter
un oeil julie jouty au prochain match et
ce qu'on a eu pour voir ce qu'ils jouent
ils jouent contre vente forest
un peu plus dangereux de france donc
après ouais et ce serait firoud jha qui
se profilerait en demie mais pour bâtir
ou de gras faudra vraiment élever le
niveau de juin ouais voilà les prag
ananda qui peut à mon avis qui peut
devenir dans les années à
dans les années prochaines un vrai
candidat à la victoire dans ce speech s
junior sur ce qu'il a montré aujourd'hui
oui bah après when the thing encore
progresser en plus après là aussi c'est
pas la priorité de prendre et c'est un
an bits dans ces formats enfin surtout
dans des formes en line mais bon
mécaniquement il progressera qu'il
progressera encore plus loin des chacun
hillingdon marges et une marge de
progression
il a une grosse marge de progression est
génial sarine y avait l'air d'être
encore plus fort que lui on verra je
crois qu'il joue aussi donc on on le
verra à l'oeuvre signalé peut-être
marc-andré à l'année prochaine
ouais bah ça ça te demandes s'il est
encore un peu de douleur était en
peut-être encore un peu tendre cette
année quand même oh oui oui qui sont
quand même en alors cette position ça
donne quoi maxime sont les pions tombe
dans une rue non mais ça doit faire
mieux ça non après wave va donner les
liens avec lui parce que là la ses pions
de la suisse gérard soutadé 5 à vii et
b5
ouais faire j'ai quatre
moi j'étais assez bien prend son temps
est ce qu'il est connecté
tu te demandes toujours en fait mal et
réfléchie là il a pris gamme énormément
de temps pour jouer ce bout d'un
terrible non plus cinq et ça fait plus 4
voilà et c'est la dernière je pense y
reste il reste une minute 8
c'est là d'ailleurs partie maxime allais
finissez sur la beauté des couleurs est
ce qu on a déjà le on n'a pas encore le
tableau du speech sas que tu ne joueras
d'heure le speech s masculins 1 à priori
oui tu vas réussir à calais ça dans ton
d'emploi ma priorité je crois que bon je
dis ça je sais plus si c'est passé en
tout cas c'est un événement tu t'amuses
quoi c'est pas oui au oui/non où ils
manière générale j'aime d'un jeu après
voici 10 est je le vérifie si j'ai déjà
donné mon accord si les bases cette
façon les dates vous pouvez plus ou
moins vous arranger nantes a presque au
cours de mes choix des dates un peu faim
même en tapant jean genre l état des
finales et qu'il était ratatat rochois
donc c'est john trucs pour pour perdre
exprès non
ce pool b et c un titre gens regagnent
le speech à ça peut être un titre qui te
fait plaisir à ton palmarès où ça reste
vraiment une compétition semi amical moi
c'est plutôt week-end après tu as comme
c'est toujours
un pub renoncer car où tu veux ça peut
les nerfs mais faut pas sous-estimer ces
mais ça reste quand même une compétition
semi amicales oui c'est pas moi c'est
pas un truc est ce que tu penses qu'un
jour des compétitions comme ça sur
internet pourront devenir pas aussi
importantes qu'en réel mais on va dire
gagner en importance dans le circuit ou
pour toi c'est pas pour bientôt
c'est peut-être pour un moment mais pas
pour tout de suite du platane est plein
et france 3 puis prendra bien orange de
dan ait promis je crois que dans l'oeuf
simplement font maintenant 1er mai
peut-être maintenant vous projettera je
prends des f3 dame elle s'improvise
cette dame 17 ans encore ça a l'air de
tenir h4 cette femme est h 4 900 projets
7,5 points à la tente pas les pièges
recueillies sur la base c'était
d'arracher cette barbe il gagne il
guigne temps et c'est la fin du match et
c'est la fin du match et ça finit à il
finit à trois points d'écart donc écoute
ça aura été s'arrêter un match un match
tendu
on s'est jouée finalement dans les
premières minutes parce qu'il a il a
mené 3-0 et c'est les trois parties du
début qui reste à la fin bon bah écoute
maxime il va être temps de quitter tout
le monde de faire un petit raid sur la
chaîne officielle si les gens veulent
suivre les interviews des joueurs
moi je vais davantage aux jeunes stream
passe à comment nous ça parce que
modelage le stream pas vrai tout ça
parce que vos tests de stream pas bien
évidemment mais là ce trimestre après
midi
et moi je vais faire je vais tenter de
faire l'aréna king juste après parce que
c'est du 960 pour moi je suis déjà la
ceca homo moi aussi je pense pas que ce
soit et j'irai porter mes exploits
ouais bon courage et n'hésitez-pas donc
à suivre la chaîne de maxime qui fera et
vous pourrez retrouver tous les live sur
le calendrier de chess comme tv france
bon pas écouté merci à tous grand merci
à toi maxime s et à bientôt
elles s'ajoutent aux 1 tous tokyo